CONNIE SCHNEIDER  --
.
--
SPEAKER:  WE'RE JUST
CONNIE SCHNEIDER  --
.
--
SPEAKER:  WE'RE JUST WAITING FOR
THE JUDGES.
--
[APPLAUSE].
SPEAKER:  THE --
SPEAKER:  THE QUALITY OF MERCY
MERCY IS NOT STRAINED.  IT
DROPS AS THE GENTLE RAIN OFTHE
GENTLE RAIN OF HEAVEN.
BLESSED HIM THAT GIVES.  AND
HIM
THAT
THAT TAKES.  ESTEEMED GUESTS,
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, I
WELCOME YOU TO THE WELCOME YOU
TO THE AUDITORIUM FOR TONIGHT'S
VERY SPECIAL
PERFORMANCE.  MY NAME IS MY NAME
IS ELIZABETH AND I'M HONORED TO
MY NAME IS ELIZABETH AND I'M
HONORED TO SERVE AS THE GENERAL
FOR THE
MY NAME IS ELIZABETH AND I'M
HONORED TO SERVE AS THE GENERAL
FOR THE LIBRARY OF CONGRESS.
I'M THRILLED TO BE ABLE TO OPEN
TONIGHT'S EVENT
ON BEHALF OF
THE LAW LIBRARY OF
THE LAW LIBRARY OF CONGRESS.
THE LAW LIBRARY IS THE CUSTODIAN
OF  OF THE WORLD'S LEGAL
MATERIAL WITH NEARLY THREE
OF THE WORLD'S LEGAL MATERIAL
WITH NEARLY THREE MILLION ITEMS
AND COUNTING, AND NUMEROUS
LANGUAGES
AND
FORMATS.  THE LAW LIBRARY SERVES
ALL BRANCHES OF THE
UNITED STATES GOVERNMENT,
PRACTICING BAR,
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT,
LOCAL GOVERNMENT, AMERICAN
BUSINESSES, SCHOLARS AND THE
WORLD LEGAL COMMUNITY.
THROUGHOUT THE  COMMUNITY.
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR, THE LIBRARY
PRESENTS PUBLIC PROGRAMS
FOCUSED
COMMUNITY.  THROUGHOUT THE
YEAR, THE LIBRARY PRESENTS
PUBLIC PROGRAMS FOCUSED ON
CURRENT
LEGAL TOPICS.  LOOK OUT FOR
EVENTS CELEBRATING
CONSTITUTION  CONSTITUTION DAY,
HUMAN RIGHTS DAY AS WELL AS THE
KELLOG LECTURE ON
JURISPRUDENCE.  TONIGHT'S
PERFORMANCE IS THE LAST OF THE
SERIES OF THREE COMMENTS
COMMEMORATING THE 500TH
ANNIVERSARY OF THE ESTABLISHMENT
OF
THE
VENICE.  ENTITLED THE CITY OF
THE JEWS, SPACE OF STRANGERS IN
THE JEWISHSTRANGERS IN THE
JEWISH BATTLE OF
STRANGERS IN THE JEWISH BATTLE
OF VENICE, AND ANOTHER THIS
OF VENICE, AND ANOTHER THIS PAST
FEBRUARY.  YOU CAN FIND VIDEOS
OF BOTH
STRANGERS IN THE JEWISH BATTLE
OF VENICE, AND ANOTHER THIS PAST
FEBRUARY.  YOU CAN FIND VIDEOS
OF BOTH OF THESE EVENTS ON THE
LAW
STRANGERS IN THE JEWISH BATTLE
OF VENICE, AND ANOTHER THIS PAST
FEBRUARY.  YOU CAN FIND VIDEOS
OF BOTH OF THESE EVENTS ON THE
LAW LIBRARY'S YOUTUBE CHANNEL.
THIS EVENT TONIGHT WAS MADE
STRANGERS IN THE JEWISH BATTLE
OF VENICE, AND ANOTHER THIS PAST
FEBRUARY.  YOU CAN FIND VIDEOS
OF BOTH OF THESE EVENTS ON THE
LAW LIBRARY'S YOUTUBE CHANNEL.
THIS EVENT TONIGHT WAS MADE
STRANGERS IN THE JEWISH BATTLE
OF VENICE, AND ANOTHER THIS PAST
FEBRUARY.  YOU CAN FIND VIDEOS
OF BOTH OF THESE EVENTS ON THE
LAW LIBRARY'S YOUTUBE CHANNEL.
THIS EVENT TONIGHT WAS MADE
POSSIBLE FROM THE
AMERICAN AMERICAN
FEDERATION. FEDERATION.  THE
FEDERATION.  THE LIBRARY
ALSO GRACED THE CONTRIBUTION
RECEIVED THROUGH THE FRIENDS OF
THETHE FRIENDS OF THE LAWTHE
FRIENDS OF THE LAW LIBRARY THE
FRIENDS OF THE LAW LIBRARY OF
CONGRESS FROMTHE FRIENDS OF THE
LAW LIBRARY OF CONGRESS FROM
THOMAS
THE FRIENDS OF THE LAW LIBRARY
OF CONGRESS FROM THOMAS RIDERS
AND
THE FRIENDS OF THE LAW LIBRARY
OF CONGRESS FROM THOMAS RIDERS
AND ADDITIONAL SUPPORTTHE
FRIENDS OF THE LAW LIBRARY OF
CONGRESS FROM THOMAS RIDERS AND
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT WASTHE
FRIENDS OF THE LAW LIBRARY OF
CONGRESS FROM THOMAS RIDERS AND
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT WAS THE
FRIENDS OF THE LAW LIBRARY OF
CONGRESS FROM THOMAS RIDERS AND
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT WAS PROVIDED
BY
THE FRIENDS OF THE LAW LIBRARY
OF CONGRESS FROM THOMAS RIDERS
AND ADDITIONAL SUPPORT WAS
PROVIDED BY MR. ROBERTTHE
FRIENDS OF THE LAW LIBRARY OF
CONGRESS FROM THOMAS RIDERS AND
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT WAS PROVIDED
BY MR. ROBERT S. ROTH THE
FRIENDS OF THE LAW LIBRARY OF
CONGRESS FROM THOMAS RIDERS AND
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT WAS PROVIDED
BY MR. ROBERT S. ROTH JUNIOR.
THE FRIENDS OF THE LAW LIBRARY
OF CONGRESS FROM THOMAS RIDERS
AND ADDITIONAL SUPPORT WAS
PROVIDED BY MR. ROBERT S. ROTH
JUNIOR.  THIS MOCK TRIAL WAS
STAGED LAST YEARTHE FRIENDS OF
THE LAW LIBRARY OF CONGRESS FROM
THOMAS RIDERS AND ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT WAS PROVIDED BY MR.
ROBERT S. ROTH JUNIOR.  THIS
MOCK TRIAL WAS STAGED LAST YEAR
IN
THE FRIENDS OF THE LAW LIBRARY
OF CONGRESS FROM THOMAS RIDERS
AND ADDITIONAL SUPPORT WAS
PROVIDED BY MR. ROBERT S. ROTH
JUNIOR.  THIS MOCK TRIAL WAS
STAGED LAST YEAR IN VENICETHE
FRIENDS OF THE LAW LIBRARY OF
CONGRESS FROM THOMAS RIDERS AND
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT WAS PROVIDED
BY MR. ROBERT S. ROTH JUNIOR.
THIS MOCK TRIAL WAS STAGED LAST
YEAR IN VENICE ASTHE FRIENDS OF
THE LAW LIBRARY OF CONGRESS FROM
THOMAS RIDERS AND ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT WAS PROVIDED BY MR.
ROBERT S. ROTH JUNIOR.  THIS
MOCK TRIAL WAS STAGED LAST YEAR
IN VENICE AS PART OF THE THE
FRIENDS OF THE LAW LIBRARY OF
CONGRESS FROM THOMAS RIDERS AND
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT WAS PROVIDED
BY MR. ROBERT S. ROTH JUNIOR.
THIS MOCK TRIAL WAS STAGED LAST
YEAR IN VENICE AS PART OF THE
CITY'S
500TH AN VERSEVERSEERSARY
VERSEERSARY COMMERATION AND WE
ARE FORTUNATE THAT THEARE
FORTUNATE THAT THE PRODUCER OF
LAST YEAR'S EVENT
ARE FORTUNATE THAT THE PRODUCER
OF LAST YEAR'S EVENT IS WITH US.
FOR TONIGHT'S PERFORMANCE, I
WOULD LIKE TO RECOGNIZE
RICHARD
SCHNEIDER
AND UNIVERSITY SCHOOL OF LAW.
[APPLAUSE].
AND THE ONLY MALE
JUDGE ON
OUR BENCH TONIGHT.  [APPLAUSE].
AND LET ME INTRODUCE THE
DISTINGUISHED CAST.
ARGUING ON BEHALF, LISA
STERNS, THE LIBRARY OF LAW YALE
LAW SCHOOL.  ARGUING ON BEHALF
OF ANTONIO AND THE REPUBLIC
OF VENICE, EUGENE GULLAND.  AND
ARGUING ON BEHALF OF SHYLOCK,
MICHAEL KLOTZ OF JONES DAY.
[APPLAUSE]. AND NOW
OUR DISTINGUISHED PANEL JUDGE
MICAELA DEL MONTE OF THE
EUROPEAN PARLIAMENT RESEARCH
SERVICE.  SUZANNE REYNOLDS,
DEAN OF WAKE
FOREST LAW.
DICK
SCHNEIDER, AMBASSADOR CONNIE
SCHNEIDER AND THE JUDGE WHO
NEEDS NO INTRODUCTION BUT I'M
GOING TO
SAY IT.  THE JUDGE WHO WILL
DELIVER THE FINAL VERDICT,
ASSOCIATE JUSTICE OF THE SUPREME
COURT OF THE UNITED STATES,
RUTH
BADER GINSBURG.  [APPLAUSE].
FINALLY PLAYING THE MAN IS
EDWARD GERO.  [APPLAUSE]. I
THINK HE WILL APPEAR LATER.
BEFORE WE GET TO THE TRIAL YOU
WILL HEAR FROM TWO SPEAKERS OF
THE AMERICAN FEDERATION, WILL
HELP US UNDERSTAND THE HISTORY
OF THE SEPHARDIC JEWS, THEIR
CONNECTION TO VENICE.  MICHAEL
KAHN OF THE SHAKESPEARE THEATRE
COMPANY WILL HELP FRAME WHAT YOU
SEE ON TONIGHT'S STAGE AND
AFTER THE JUDGES TAKE RECESS FOR
DELIBERATIONS YOU WILL HEAR
FROM JIM SHAPIRO FROM COLOMBIA
UNIVERSITY WHO WILL GO INTO MORE
DEPTHS ABOUT THE MERCHANT OF
VENICE DURING SHAKESPEARE'S
TIME.  BEFORE YOUR PERFORMANCE I
WOULD LIKE TO KINDLY REMIND YOU
TO SWITCH YOUR MOBILE PHONES
AND OTHER DEVICES TO THE SILENT
MODE AND PLEASE NOTE THAT
TONIGHT'S PROGRAM IS BEING
RECORDED AS A FACEBOOK LIVE
STREAM AND WILL BE ON THE LAW
LIBRARY'S
YOUTUBE
CHANNEL.  I WOULD LIKE TO
INVITE DAVID
TO THE
STAGE.
SPEAKER:  THANK YOU LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN AND THE
SEPHARDIC FEDERATION, I AM VERY
PLEASED TO STAND
IN FRONT OF YOU AND BE A
SPONSOR OF TODAY'S INTERESTING
EVENT.  AND OBVIOUSLY IT'S A
GREAT HONOR FOR US
TO BE ASSOCIATED WITH THE
DISTINGUISHED PANEL OF JUDGES.
AND JUDGE GINSBERG.  I WILL VERY
PREVIOUSLY JUST TELL YOU
SOMETHING IN CONTEXT ABOUT THIS
PLAY.  AND THE IMPORTANCE TO
JEWISH HISTORY.  AMERICAN
SEPHARDIC FEDERATION IS HISTORIC
AND WE STUDY THE HISTORY AND WE
PRESERVE AND PROMOTE THE
HISTORY OF WHAT I CALL THE
UNKNOWN JEWS.
THERE IS A VERY LARGE CONTINGENT
OF JEWS THAT COME FROM THE
MIDDLE EAST, THE FAR EAST, NORTH
AFRICA AND ORIGINALLY SOME
OF THEM FROM SPAIN, AND
PORTUGAL.
THEY ARE LARGELY FOR GOTTEN IN
HISTORY TODAY AND YOU WILL WANT
TO SEE WHY THEY ARE ASSOCIATED
IN THIS EVENT.  FROM THE
PENINSULA, THE MIDDLE EAST, THE
FAR EAST, AND IMPORTANTLY, THE
JEWS CAME HERE VERY EARLY, BY
MAINLY THE CARIBBEAN AND IT'S
THEREFORE A PLEASURE TODAY BY
THE AMERICAN SEPHARDIC
FEDERATION TO CONVEY THAT
WE HAVE SINCE LONG ADOPTED THE
MERCHANT OF VENICE AS A
SEPHARDIC JEW.  JEW ORIGINATING
TO THE MASS EXIDUS OF JEWS FROM
THE SYBERIAN PENINSULA.  AND WE
AT THE SEPHARDIC FEDERATION
GUARD IT AMONG SEVERAL OTHER.
THERE ARE HINTS IN SHAKESPEARE
PLAY THAT THIS IS PROBABLY A
SEPHARDIC JEW FROM SPAIN.
BEFORE I EXPLAIN, ALLOW ME FIRST
TO OUTLINE WHY IN SOME WAY THE
MERCHANT OF VENICE IS VIEWED AS
A GIFT TO THE PEOPLE OF
SHAKESPEARE.  THIS IS THE
PERSPECTIVE.  BECAUSE OF THE
UNDERSTANDABLE AND ENORMOUS
TENSION TO THE HORRORS OF THE
HOLOCAUST, THERE IS LITTLE FOCUS
IN INTEREST TO REMIND US TODAY
TO THE TERRIBLE FLIGHT IN EUROPE
FROM THE PEOPLE IN THE EARLY
PERIOD FROM THE HOLOCAUST AND
THE MASSIVE ATTACK AND THE DRIVE
OF JEWS IN 1948.  BECAUSE OF
THE BRILLIANCE AND FAME OF
SHAKESPEARE AND THE BRILLIANCE
OF HIS PLAY, THE MERCHANT OF
VENICE IS A REMINDER OF THE
JEWISH
PEOPLE.  HELP TO REBUILD JEWISH
HISTORY, INCLUDING FOR EXAMPLE
THE SLAUGHTER OF THE LARGE
JEWISH COMMUNITIES ALONG
THE RIVER IN EUROPE IN SOUTHERN
FRANCE AND MASS EXPULSION IN
SPAIN, PORTUGAL, SISILY, AND
VENICE AND MANY OTHER PARTS OF
THE MEDITERRANEAN.  IN TIMES OF
SHAKESPEARE WRITING THE PLAY,
THERE WAS VERSES INCLUDING IN
VENICE AND IN ENGLAND AT THE
TIME, ENGLAND WAS IN THE
ELIZABETHIAN ERA WHICH WAS VERY
ANTI-JEWISH.  JEWS WERE ONLY
ALLOWED BACK IN 1656, 60 YEARS
AFTER THE MERCHANT OF VENICE.
IN SUMMARY, IT'S NOTE WORTHY
THAT THE PLAY AT THE TIME ONLY
DEALS WITH BASICALLY FINANCIAL
MATTERS AND NOT SOMETHING MUCH
WORSE.  WHICH WOULD HAVE BEEN
TYPICAL OF THE DAY.  IN OTHER
WORDS, FOR THIS REASON, AND THE
FAMOUS MONOLOGUE IN THE PLAY,
OPTIMISTICALLY VIEWED, THIS IS
ONE OF THE EARLIER EUROPEAN
ATTEMPTS TO HUMANIZE
JEWS.  THE NEXT ATTEMPT IN
ENGLAND REALLY ONLY CAME WITH
THE POPULAR NOVEL IN 1820 WITH
REBECCA AND HER FATHER BEING
AMONG THE LEAD CHARACTERS.
PERHAPS EVEN PAVING THE WAY FOR
ISRAELI MINISTERS, 200 YEARS
AFTER THE MERCHANTS OF VENICE.
WHERE JEWS HAD TO LIVE WAS
CONSTITUTED IN 1516 AS YOU
HEARD.
AND SEVERAL VERY  VERY
WELL-KNOWN SEPHARDIC JEWS CAME
TO VENICE AND ALLOWED
TO LIVE
MORE
FREELY.  AND BY THE GHETTO THE
STRICT
BOUNDARIES WERE SWEEPING
THE ROUNDS THE ROUNDS OF THE
CATHOLIC CHURCH.  AREAS, THE
GHETTO AND THE ADJACENT
GHETTO.
THESE NAMES OF THE GHETTOS ARE
MISLEADING.  FROM DIFFERENT
GHETTO.
THESE NAMES OF THE GHETTOS ARE
MISLEADING.  FROM DIFFERENT
BACKGROUNDS CAME TO LIVE IN THE
GHETTO.  AND
GHETTO.
THESE NAMES OF THE GHETTOS ARE
MISLEADING.  FROM DIFFERENT
BACKGROUNDS CAME TO LIVE IN THE
GHETTO.  AND OVERTIME THEY HAD
DEVELOPED A DISTINCT VENITIAN
IDENTITY AND KNEW STRONGLY TO
IDENTIFY WITH THEIR TO IDENTIFY
WITH THEIR ORIGINS AND THEREFORE
FOUR OF THE FIVE SYNAGOGUES,
ACCORDING TO
ETHNIC IDENTITY IN THE GHETTO.
THE GERMAN SYNAGOGUE, THE
ITALIAN SYNAGOGUE,
THE ITALIAN AND PORTOGESE AND
THE 5TH SYNAGOGUE THAT WAS BUILT
SPECIFICALLY FOR USE.  THE
LANGUAGES SPOKEN AT
THE TIME IN THE GHETTO, INCLUDED
VENETIAN,
ITALIAN, SPANISH, ARABIC,
SPANISH, FRENCH
AND GERMAN AND WHILE HEBREW WAS
TRADITIONALLY USED FOR OFFICIAL
PURPOSES, AND OF COURSE IN
RELIGIOUS SERVICES.  ALLOW ME
FINALLY
A QUICK BACKGROUND ON THE WORD
GHETTO.  LIKE WITH SO MUCH ABOUT
THE PLAY, THERE ARE DIFFERENT
EXPLANATIONS AND THEORIES.
ABOUT THE ORIGINS OF THE WORD.
SOME SAY THE WORD ORIGINATES
FROM THE FOUNDERS IN VENICE
WHERE THE ITALIAN WROTE GHETTO.
IT'S VERY SIMILAR TO GHETTO.
BUT IT'S MOST LIKELY THAT THE
WORD GHETTO DERIVES FROM THE
CATHOLIC WORD GATTO WHICH MEANS
STREET AND THE REASON FOR THAT
IS THAT THE JEWS, THROUGHOUT
THE MIDDLE AGES, USUALLY
CONGREGATED ALONG ONE STREET
WHERE THEY WOULD HAVE ALL THE
SHOPS AND PLACES OF COMMERCE.
SO IT WAS
VERY EASY TO DECIDE TO ENCLOSE
A STREET LIKE THAT AND PUT
BOUNDARIES.
JEWS GHETTO AND THE 28-YEAR-OLD
NAPOLEON IN 1797, FOLLOWING THE
CONQUEST OF THE NATION.  THAT'S
WHAT YOU NEED TO KNOW.  THANK
YOU.  [APPLAUSE].
SPEAKER:  EVENING.  I HAVE BEEN
GIVEN THE TASK OF EXPLAINING TO
YOU A PLAY THAT I
THINK YOU HAVE ALL SEEN AND
READ.  BUT I WILL MAYBE REFRESH
YOUR MIND ABOUT THE STORY.  JUST
LET ME TELL YOU THAT IT WAS
FIRST PUBLISHED IN 1600.
YOU THAT IT WAS FIRST PUBLISHED
IN 1600.  AND THAT MUCH OF THE
TIME, TOOK THE
STORIES
STORIES THAT HE HAD READ, THAT
WERE WRITTEN EARLIER.  ONE WAS
THE STORY OF THE BOND OF PLEDGE
AND THE OTHER WAS
THE STORY OF THE CASKETS.  NOW
THE MERCHANT OF VENICE, WE VERY
OFTEN CONFUSE THE FACT, WE THINK
THAT THE
DIALECT IS SUCH A CHARACTER.  WE
THINK THAT
A CHARACTER.  WE THINK THAT THE
MERCHANT OF VENICE IS
MERCHANT OF VENICE IS SHYLOCK.
BUT HE IS THE REAL MERCHANT OF
A CHARACTER.  WE THINK THAT THE
MERCHANT OF VENICE IS SHYLOCK.
BUT HE IS THE REAL MERCHANT OF
VENICE.  IN THE BEGINNING OF THE
PLAY, ANTONIO, WITH
A CHARACTER.  WE THINK THAT THE
MERCHANT OF VENICE IS SHYLOCK.
BUT HE IS THE REAL MERCHANT OF
VENICE.  IN THE BEGINNING OF THE
PLAY, ANTONIO, WITH SEVERAL OF
HIS FRIENDS, YOUNG MEN WITH WHOM
ARE DESANIO
AND
LOREZNO.  LOREZNO.   LOREZNO.
DESANIO CAME TO ANTONIO,
ADMITTING
THAT HE HAD HE HAD SPENT A LOT
OF
ANTONIO'S MONEY TRYING TO
BETTERMONEY TRYING TO BETTER
HIMSELF AND ALSO BUYING A LOT OF
VERY GOOD ITEMS AND CLOTHES AND
MADE A GREAT MAN ABOUT TIME.
AND HE TELLS ANTONIO
THAT HE HAS THE POSSIBILITY OF
REPAYING ALL OF THAT MONEY
AGAIN,
BECAUSE HE
HAS FOUND A BEAUTIFUL
HEIR LIVING OUTSIDE AN ISLAND
NAMED PORSHA AND WISHES TO HAVE
HER
HAND IN MARRIAGE AND DOESN'T
HAVE MUCH MONEY AT THE MOMENT.
AND SAYS TO YOU, I WANT
TO DO THIS AND GOES TO THE ONLY
PLACE WHERE HE CAN GET THAT
MONEY, AND THAT IS
TO SHYLOCK, WHO SHYLOCK TELLS
HIM FIRST,HIM FIRST, OF COURSE,
HOW BADLY HE AND HIS FELLOW JEWS
HAD BEEN TREATED BY THE
MERCHANTS OF VENICE AND YET COME
TO HIM FOR MONEY.
BUT HE SAYS, ISAYS, I WILL DO
THIS.  AND IN THE PROCESS OF
THIS NEGOTIATION
SAYS,
YOU KNOW, I AM NOT GOING TO
CHARGE YOU
ANYTHING.  I JUST WANT.  LET ME
SAY, I'LL TAKE A POUND OF YOUR
FLESH.  TO BE CUT FROM WHEREVER
AND YOUR BODY I WISH.  ANTONIO
WHO HAS BEEN A SUCCESSFUL
MERCHANT FINDS THIS ACTUALLY A
CHARITABLE REQUEST, BECAUSE
IT'S BASICALLY IMPOSSIBLE.  AND
HE COMES HOME WITH THE MONEY
AND BESANIO
GOES OFF TO BELLMONT
FOR PORSHA.  AND WE SHOULD
MENTION YOUNG LORENZO.  WHO HAS
SEEN AND PERHAPS BECOME
ATTRACTIVE AND FALLEN IN LOVE
WITH
A YOUNG JEW WHO LIVES IN THE
GHETTO.
JESSICA.  IN THE PLAY RATHER
EARLY ON, LORENZO ABDUCTS
JESSICA, QUITE WILLINGLY WHO
LEAVES THE GHETTO AND HER FATHER
WITH A
GREAT DEAL OF HIS MONEY.
SHYLOCK IS DEEPLY, DEEPLY,
DEEPLY DISTRESSED
BY THIS.
DISASTROUS.  THE SHIPS ARE
WRECKED AND CANNOT PAY SHYLOCK
BACK.  THIS
COMES VERY SOON AFTER SHYLOCK
-- HIS DAUGHTER HAS BEEN STOLEN
AND SHYLOCK DEMANDS THAT THE
BOND BE PAID.
AND THAT THE POUND OF FLESH BE
TAKEN FROM ANTONIO'S BODY.  HERE
IS A GREAT TRIAL WHICH WILL BE
DISCUSSED TONIGHT.  THE TRIAL.
PORSHA
ARRIVES, DRESSED AS A MAN AND
PRETENDS TO BE
A LAWYER.
AND EVENTUALLY WINS
ANTONIO'S SUIT.  THIS
END NOT ONLY HAS TO GIVE HIS
MONEY, BUT ALSO ASKED
AND TOLD THAT HE MUST FEED THAT
TIE AS A CHRISTIAN AT THE END
OF THIS TRIAL.  THIS PLAY,
EVERYBODY GOES BACK TO BELLMONT
AND SEEMS TO GET ALONG VERY
WELL.  OTHER PRODUCTIONS, NOT SO
WELL.  AND IT IS WHY SHYLOCK
WHO ENDS THE
4TH ACT.  AND THE AND THE 5TH
ACT IS BELMONT AND THAT'S WHY
THIS PLAY IS ALWAYS PUT FIRST
FOR COMEDIES, BECAUSE IT SEEMS
TO HAVE A HAPPY ENDING.  BUT
THERE IS NO QUESTION THAT THE
RESIDENT ISSUE OF THIS PLAY AND
THE LARGER PART OF THIS PLAY IS
SHYLOCK AND HIS FAITH.  AND
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE GOING TO TALK
ABOUT TONIGHT.  [APPLAUSE].
SPEAKER: EVENING.  IN THIS FIRST
SPEECH
SHYLOCK EXPRESSES
HIS SURPRISE QUEST.  SENIOR
ANTONIO, MANY TIME OFTEN YOU
HAVE RATED ME ABOUT MY USE.
BORN WITH THE PATIENT SHRUG OR
SUFFERING IS THE BAD OF ALL
THE TRIBE.  YOU CALL YOU CALL
ME MR. BELIEVER.  AND
UPON
MY JEWISH
GATHERING, AND ALL FOR
USE OF THAT WHICH
USE OF THAT WHICH IS MY OWN.
WELL, THEN, NOW IT APPEARS
THAT
THAT YOU NEED ME.  GO TO THEM.
YOU
COME TO ME AND SAY
SHYLOCK, WE WOULD HAVE MONEY.
YOU
YOU SAY
YOU SAY SO.
YOU.
YOU.  AND OCCUR
YOU SAY SO.
YOU.  AND OCCUR OVER THE BULB.
WHAT
YOU SAY SO.
YOU.  AND OCCUR OVER THE BULB.
WHAT SHOULD
YOU SAY SO.
YOU.  AND OCCUR OVER THE BULB.
WHAT SHOULD ISIR, YOU SPIN
ME ON WEDNESDAY.  YOU SPUN ME
SUCH A DAY.  ANOTHER  A DAY.
ANOTHER TIME YOU CALLED ME DOG
AND FOR THESE THESE COURTESIES,
ITHESE COURTESIES, I WILL
THESE COURTESIES, I WILL LEND
YOU
YOU THIS MUCH
THESE COURTESIES, I WILL LEND
YOU THIS MUCH MONEY.
YOU THIS MUCH MONEY.  IN THE
THESE COURTESIES, I WILL LEND
NEXT SPEECH, SHYLOCK IS
DISCUSSING THE TERMS OF HIS
THESE COURTESIES, I WILL LEND
YOU THIS MUCH MONEY.  IN THE
NEXT SPEECH, SHYLOCK IS
DISCUSSING THE TERMS OF HIS
LOAN, SHOULD ANTONIO DO IT.  AND
HE REVEALS
THESE COURTESIES, I WILL LEND
YOU THIS MUCH MONEY.  IN THE
NEXT SPEECH, SHYLOCK IS
DISCUSSING THE TERMS OF HIS
LOAN, SHOULD ANTONIO DO IT.  AND
HE REVEALS WHAT HE VALUES IN A
THESE COURTESIES, I WILL LEND
YOU THIS MUCH MONEY.  IN THE
NEXT SPEECH, SHYLOCK IS
DISCUSSING THE TERMS OF HIS
LOAN, SHOULD ANTONIO DO IT.  AND
HE REVEALS WHAT HE VALUES IN A
THESE COURTESIES, I WILL LEND
YOU THIS MUCH MONEY.  IN THE
NEXT SPEECH, SHYLOCK IS
DISCUSSING THE TERMS OF HIS
LOAN, SHOULD ANTONIO DO IT.  AND
HE REVEALS WHAT HE VALUES IN A
POUND OFTHESE COURTESIES, I WILL
LEND YOU THIS MUCH MONEY.  IN
THE NEXT SPEECH, SHYLOCK IS
DISCUSSING THE TERMS OF HIS
LOAN, SHOULD ANTONIO DO IT.  AND
HE REVEALS WHAT HE VALUES IN A
POUND OF THESE COURTESIES, I
WILL LEND YOU THIS MUCH MONEY.
IN THE NEXT SPEECH, SHYLOCK IS
DISCUSSING THE TERMS OF HIS
LOAN, SHOULD ANTONIO DO IT.  AND
HE REVEALS WHAT HE VALUES IN A
POUND OF FLESH.
THESE COURTESIES, I WILL LEND
YOU THIS MUCH MONEY.  IN THE
NEXT SPEECH, SHYLOCK IS
DISCUSSING THE TERMS OF HIS
LOAN, SHOULD ANTONIO DO IT.  AND
HE REVEALS WHAT HE VALUES IN A
POUND OF FLESH.  TO BAKE FISH
WITH ALL.  IT WILL FEED NOTHING
ELSE, ITTHESE COURTESIES, I WILL
LEND YOU THIS MUCH MONEY.  IN
THE NEXT SPEECH, SHYLOCK IS
DISCUSSING THE TERMS OF HIS
LOAN, SHOULD ANTONIO DO IT.  AND
HE REVEALS WHAT HE VALUES IN A
POUND OF FLESH.  TO BAKE FISH
WITH ALL.  IT WILL FEED NOTHING
ELSE, IT WILL FEEDTHESE
COURTESIES, I WILL LEND YOU THIS
MUCH MONEY.  IN THE NEXT
SPEECH, SHYLOCK IS DISCUSSING
THE TERMS OF HIS LOAN, SHOULD
ANTONIO DO IT.  AND HE REVEALS
WHAT HE VALUES IN A POUND OF
FLESH.  TO BAKE FISH WITH ALL.
IT WILL FEED NOTHING ELSE, IT
WILL FEED MY REVENGE.
THESE COURTESIES, I WILL LEND
YOU THIS MUCH MONEY.  IN THE
NEXT SPEECH, SHYLOCK IS
DISCUSSING THE TERMS OF HIS
LOAN, SHOULD ANTONIO DO IT.  AND
HE REVEALS WHAT HE VALUES IN A
POUND OF FLESH.  TO BAKE FISH
WITH ALL.  IT WILL FEED NOTHING
ELSE, IT WILL FEED MY REVENGE.
YOU HAVE DISGRACED ME.  AND
THESE COURTESIES, I WILL LEND
YOU THIS MUCH MONEY.  IN THE
NEXT SPEECH, SHYLOCK IS
DISCUSSING THE TERMS OF HIS
LOAN, SHOULD ANTONIO DO IT.  AND
HE REVEALS WHAT HE VALUES IN A
POUND OF FLESH.  TO BAKE FISH
WITH ALL.  IT WILL FEED NOTHING
ELSE, IT WILL FEED MY REVENGE.
YOU HAVE DISGRACED ME.  AND
HINDERED ME HALF A MILLION.
ENOUGH THAT MY LOSS ISTHESE
COURTESIES, I WILL LEND YOU THIS
MUCH MONEY.  IN THE NEXT
SPEECH, SHYLOCK IS DISCUSSING
THE TERMS OF HIS LOAN, SHOULD
ANTONIO DO IT.  AND HE REVEALS
WHAT HE VALUES IN A POUND OF
FLESH.  TO BAKE FISH WITH ALL.
IT WILL FEED NOTHING ELSE, IT
WILL FEED MY REVENGE.
YOU HAVE DISGRACED ME.  AND
HINDERED ME HALF A MILLION.
ENOUGH THAT MY LOSS IS MARKED AT
THESE COURTESIES, I WILL LEND
YOU THIS MUCH MONEY.  IN THE
NEXT SPEECH, SHYLOCK IS
DISCUSSING THE TERMS OF HIS
LOAN, SHOULD ANTONIO DO IT.  AND
HE REVEALS WHAT HE VALUES IN A
POUND OF FLESH.  TO BAKE FISH
WITH ALL.  IT WILL FEED NOTHING
ELSE, IT WILL FEED MY REVENGE.
YOU HAVE DISGRACED ME.  AND
HINDERED ME HALF A MILLION.
ENOUGH THAT MY LOSS IS MARKED AT
MYTHESE COURTESIES, I WILL LEND
YOU THIS MUCH MONEY.  IN THE
NEXT SPEECH, SHYLOCK IS
DISCUSSING THE TERMS OF HIS
LOAN, SHOULD ANTONIO DO IT.  AND
HE REVEALS WHAT HE VALUES IN A
POUND OF FLESH.  TO BAKE FISH
WITH ALL.  IT WILL FEED NOTHING
ELSE, IT WILL FEED MY REVENGE.
YOU HAVE DISGRACED ME.  AND
HINDERED ME HALF A MILLION.
ENOUGH THAT MY LOSS IS MARKED AT
MY GAINS.  GO ON
COOLED MY
FRIENDS.  PAINTED MY ENEMIES.
AND WHAT'S HIS
HIS  HIS REASON?
I'M
I'M A
JEW.
OTHER JEW EYES.
OTHER JEW HANDS, ORGANS,
DIMENSIONS, SENSES, PASSIONS.
FED WITH THE SAME FOOD.  HURT
WITH THE SAME WEAPONS.  SUBJECT
TO THE SAME DISEASES.  HEALED BY
THE SAME MEANS.  WARMED AND
COOLED BY THE SAME SUMMER THAT A
CHRISTIAN IS.  DO NOT BLEED.
IF YOU TICKLE US, IF YOU POISON
US, DO WE NOT DIE.  AND IF YOU
ARE AMONG US, SHALL WE NOT
REVENGE.
WHEN WE REST, WE WILL
RESEMBLE YOU IN THAT.  WHAT IS
HIS HUMILITY?  REVENGE.  A
CHRISTIAN OR A JEW, WHAT SHOULD
HIS SUFFERANCE BE BY CHRISTIAN
FOR EXAMPLE?  WHY REVENGE?  THE
VILLIAN YOU TEACH ME, I SHALL
EXECUTE AND IT SHALL GO HARD.
BUT I WILL BETTER.  LASTLY,
SHALL I USE IN COURT AGAINST
USING MERCY TO TEMPER JUSTICE IN
THE HOPES OF RECEIVING THE
SAME KINDNESS IN GOD'S FINAL
JUDGMENT.  WHAT JUDGMENT SHALL I
DREAD DOING NO WRONG?  MANY
APPROACH THE SLAVES LIKE
WHAT WHAT YOU USE IN OBJECTS
FOR SLAVES BECAUSE YOU BOUGHT
THEM.  SHALL I SAY TO YOU IT
CAN BE FREE, MARRY THEM TO YOUR
HEIRS.
BURDENS, LET THE BEDS BE MADE AS
SOFT AS YOURS.  AND LET THEIR
PAST BE WITH
SUCH DEMONS.  YOU WILL SAVE US.
HOW DO I ANSWER YOU?  THE
POUND OF FLESH WHICH I DEMAND OF
HIM IS DEARLY BOUGHT.
IT'S
BOUGHT.
IT'S MINE.  AND I WILL HAVE IT.
IF YOU
DENY
ME, PRY UPON THE HORSE INTO THE
CREASE OF
VENICE.
JUDGMENT.  ANSWER.  SHALL
I HAVE IT?  [APPLAUSE].
PROCEED WITH SHYLOCK APPEAL.
BEFORE WE DO SO, LET ME CAUTION
COUNSEL THAT THE BENCH IS HAVING
GREAT DIFFICULTY HEARING.  SO
YOU MIGHT TIP THE PODIUM
SLIGHTLY.
SAFELY.  WE WILL HEAR FIRST FROM
SHYLOCK'S COUNSEL.
SPEAKER:  GOOD AFTERNOON, YOUR
HONOR.
I'M MICHAEL KLOTZ FOR THE
APPELLANT.  BEFORE WE BEGIN I
WOULD LIKE TO RESERVE
TWO MINUTES FOR REBUTTAL.
THERE ARE TWO CENTRAL ISSUES IN
THIS
APPEAL.  THE FIRST ISSUE IS
WHETHER THE PARTIES THAT HAVE
ENTERED INTO AN AGREEMENT
HAVEN'T FULFILLED ITS
OBLIGATIONS AND ABLE TO KEEP THE
FRUITS OF THE AGREEMENT.
TO KEEP THE FRUITS OF THE
AGREEMENT.  MY CLIENT SHYLOCK
ENTERED INTO A LOAN AGREEMENT
FOR 3,000
DOCKETS AND LENT TO BASANIO AND
ANTONIO WAS THE GUARANTOR FOR
THAT AND THE MONEY WAS DUE AND
THE LOAN
WAS NOT REPAID AND TO THIS DAY,
ANTONIO CONTINUES TO HOLD THE
MONEY AND NO INTEREST HAS BEEN
PAID AND MY PAID AND MY CLIENT
HAS BEEN OUT OF LUCK.  THE ISSUE
IN THIS
APPEAL IS WHETHER A NON-CITIZEN
WHO
GOES TO A COURT AND DRAFTS A
LEGAL JUDGMENT CAN, IN DOING
SO, COMMIT A CRIMINAL ACT.  AND
THAT IS WHAT MY CLIENT HAS BEEN
CONVICTED OF.  SHYLOCK WENT TO
COURT AND ASKED TO HAVE THE
CONTRACT ENFORCED AND HE ASKED
SPECIFICALLY TO HAVE THE PENALTY
PROVISION
ENFORCED.  AND UNBE
UNBEKNOWNST TO
HIM, PORSHA WAS DESCRIBED AS A
JUDGE AND SHE IS NOT A JUDGE.
ISSUED A JUDGMENT AGAINST HIM
AND FOUND THAT HE VIOLATED THE
ALIEN ACT WHICH PROTECTS ANY
NON-CITIZEN
LIFE OF A CITIZEN.  AND SO IN
MAKING THIS APPEAL TO THE COURT,
PLEASE GIVE ME THE MONEY DUE
UNDER THIS AGREEMENT, PORSHA
SAID THIS WAS ATTEMPTED MURDER
AND OUR ARGUMENT ON THAT ISSUE
WAS, THAT CAN'T BE.  IT CAN'T BE
THE CASE THAT WHEN SOMEBODY
GOES TO A COURT AND ASKS FOR
JUSTICE, THAT
THAT'S A CRIME.  SO WE ASK THAT
THE JUDGE BE
REVERSED WITHOUT RETRIAL, AND
ANYTHING ELSE THAT THE JUDGE
DEEMS FIT.
SPEAKER:  I WOULD LIKE
CLARIFICATION ON TWO POINTS.
ONE, ARE YOU DEMANDING THE POUND
OF FLESH OR HAVE YOU
RELINQUISHED THAT REQUEST?
RELINQUISHING THE REQUEST AND
BELIEVE THAT WAS LEGAL.
SPEAKER:  SO YOU ARE DEMANDING
RETURN OF YOUR
MONEY.  YOU SAID INTEREST BUT I
THINK THE RECORD SHOWS THAT AT
THE TIME THIS LOAN WAS
NEGOTIATED, YOU SAID MY MONEY.
YOU WERE GIVING THE MONEY AND
YOU WERE NOT DEMANDING INTEREST.
YOU WERE DEMANDING ONLY THE
POUND OF FLESH.  IS IT NOT TRUE
THAT YOU RELINQUISHED
ANY CLAIMS OF INTEREST?
SPEAKER:  YOUR HONOR, IN THAT
SAME NEGOTIATION, MY CLIENT
REFERENCED THAT WHEN THE LOAN
CAME DUE, THAT HE WOULD BE GIVEN
SUCH SUMS AS DUE UNDER THE
AGREEMENT SO I THINK IT WOULD BE
UP TO THE COURT TO EXAMINE THE
CONTRACT AND DETERMINE WHETHER
THERE IS PREJUDGMENT INTEREST.
THE PREJUDGMENT INTEREST IS FOR
THE THREE MONTH PERIOD OF THE
LOAN AND THE POST JUDGMENT
INTEREST IS WHEN THE
LOAN CAME
DUE UNTIL TODAY.  [LAUGHTER].
SPEAKER:  THERE IS ANOTHER
UNUSUAL FEATURE OF THIS
PROCEEDING.  ANTONIO IS SURE
THAT THE BENEFICIARY OF THE LOAN
IS BASANIO BUT YOU ARE NOT
SUING BASANIO.  YOU BROUGHT A
SUIT AGAINST ANTONIO.
SPEAKER:  THAT'S CORRECT YOUR
HONOR, HE WAS THE GUARANTOR OF
THE LOAN AND WAS THE RECIPIENT
FOR THE UNDER LYING MONEY FOR
THIS AGREEMENT.
SPEAKER:  EVEN THOUGH YOU KNEW
FAIR WELL THAT BESANIO COULD PAY
BACK THE LOAN AND THEN THERE
WOULD BE NO CLAIM AGAINST
SHYLOCK.
SPEAKER:  YOU'RE CORRECT, YOUR
HONOR.  WE CHOSE THE DEFENDANT
AND WE DIDN'T SUE BESANIO.
SPEAKER:  COUNSEL, WHY IS IT
THAT YOU'RE ASKING FOR THE MONEY
NOW WHEN YOU WERE OFFERED THE
MONEY AT TRIAL AND
REFUSED IT?
SPEAKER:  WELL OUR POSITION HAS
CHANGED YOUR HONOR.
[LAUGHTER].
AT TRIAL WE WERE REQUESTING
SPECIFIC PERFORMANCE AND IT
WASN'T GIVEN TO US.  AND WE THEN
ASKED FOR THE MONEY AND WE WERE
TOLD THAT THAT WAS IMPOSSIBLE.
IN A WAY THAT, AS I BELIEVE THE
COURT WILL REALIZE, IS TOTALLY
IMPROPER.  SHE INTERPRETED THE
AGREEMENT TO ALLOW A POUND OF
FLESH BUT TO ALLOW NO BLOOD AND
ABSOLUTELY NO MORE OR LESS THAN
A POUND OF FLESH.  SO SHE
INTERPRETED THE AGREEMENT IN A
WAY THAT IT COULDN'T BE
PERFORMED.
SPEAKER:  MR. KLOTZ, WHAT ROLE
DO YOU THINK PORSHA'S DECEPTION
PLAYS IN THIS PROCEEDING?
SPEAKER:  PORSHA'S DECEPTION IS
EGREGIOUSEGREGIOUS.  SHE IS NOT
AN ATTORNEY.  SHE IS NOT A
JUDGE.
SHE IS NOT A PART OF ANY COURT.
SHE OBVIOUSLY MISREPRESENTED WHO
SHE WAS AND I THINK PERHAPS
MOST SIGNIFICANTLY, SHE WAS
MARRIED TO BESANIO WHO JUSTICE
GINSBURG POINTED OUT WAS ON THE
LOAN AND HAD FINANCIAL INTEREST
IN THE OUTCOME.
SPEAKER:  AND WHAT SPECIFIC
DEFENSE DOES THAT GIVE YOUR
CLIENT?
SPEAKER:  WELL I MEAN IF SHE WAS
ACTUALLY A JUDGE, SHE SHOULD
HAVE REFUSED HERSELF AND BECAUSE
SHE WAS NOT A JUDGE, THE
JUDGMENT IS COMPLETELY VOID.
AND INVALID.
SPEAKER:  DID YOU NEED A
DEFENSE?  YOU'RE THE PLAINTIFF
IN THIS SUIT?  SHYLOCK IS THE
PLAINTIFF SUING ANTONIO.
SPEAKER:  CORRECT.  CORRECT.
SPEAKER:  AND THE ROLE OF
REVENGE, SHYLOCK IS REPEATING
THAT IN MANY DIFFERENT WAYS SO
THAT HE WAS REVENGED AND
CONNECTED TO HIS INTENT.  SO HIS
INTENT WAS FOR A VERY
FATALISTIC ENDING FOR ANTONIO.
HOW DO YOU FIT THAT INTO SAYING
THAT YOU ARE TRYING TO DEFEND
SHYLOCK?
SPEAKER:  SHYLOCK HAS BEEN
MISUNDERSTOOD AND THE POINT OF
REVENGE, IT'S TRUE THAT -- IT'S
TRUE THAT MY CLIENT AND ANTONIO
WERE NOT THE BEST OF FRIENDS.
BUT HE HAD TWO OTHER MOTIVES IN
PURSUING THE PENALTY PROVISION.
AND HE MADE THAT VERY CLEAR
DURING THE PROCEEDING.  AND ONE
OF THOSE POINTS THAT HE WAS
SEEKING IS TO
FINALLY HAVE THE CHANCE UNDER
THE LAW.  IT PUNISHES
NON-CITIZENS IN A DISTANT
MANNER.  AS WE HEARD ALREADY,
JEWISH CITIZENS WERE FORCED TO
LIVE IN THE GHETTO, THEY HAD A
CURFEW AND CAN ONLY TAKE CERTAIN
OCCUPATIONS AND ACTUALLY HAD TO
PAY TO HAVE THE GHETTO PATROL.
BUT AS THE COURT IS AWARE,
FREEDOM OF CONTRACT IS ONE OF
THE GREAT THINGS THAT WHATEVER
THE GENERALLY APPLICABLE LAW IS,
TWO PEOPLE CAN SIT DOWN AND
AGREE, THIS IS WHAT YOU WILL DO,
THIS IS WHAT I WILL DO AND THEY
MAKE THEIR OWN LAW ESSENTIALLY.
SO MY CLIENT WAS VERY ANGRY
AND VERY UPSET WHERE IN THIS ONE
ASPECT OF HIS LIFE THAT HE
COULD CONTROL, HIS RIGHTS WERE
NOT BEING RECOGNIZED.
SPEAKER:  WE HEARD THAT SHYLOCK
WAS IN A STATE OF EXTREME
DISTRESS.  ARE YOU MAKING ANY
PLEAS THAT HE WOULD BE
INCOMPETENT TO HAVE BEEN
ACCUSED OF A CRIMINAL ACTION
BECAUSE HE WAS SO DISTRAUGHT AT
HIS DAUGHTER AND STEP OF THE
WORDILY GOODS.
SPEAKER:  YOUR HONOR WE ARE NOT
ARGUING THAT SHYLOCK WAS
INCOMPETENTINCOMPETENT.  WE ARE
ARGUING THAT FIRST OF ALL HE
DIDN'T HAVE AN INTEND TO MURDER
ANTONIO.
HIS INTENT WAS TO REBEL AGAINST
THE CIRCUMSTANCE THAT HE FOUND
HIMSELF IN AND ON THE SECOND
POINT THAT EVEN IF THE COURT
WERE SOMEHOW TO FIND THAT HE HAD
AN INTENT TO MURDER, THERE IS
NO ACT.  THERE IS NO ACT OF
ACTUALLY DOING ANYTHING.  HE
CAN'T BE CONVICTED
FOR MURDEROUS WORDS ANY MORE
THAN ANYONE ELSE COULD SAYING I
WANT TO DO THIS.
HIS SITUATION, YOUR HONOR, WOULD
BE COMPARABLE TO A MURDER TRIAL
WHERE THE PARENT COMES IN TO
THE COURT AND SAYS THIS MAN
SHOULD BE EXECUTED AND THIS
PERSON IS ARRESTED FOR MURDER.
THAT WOULD BE A RELATIVELY
SIMILAR SITUATION.
>> YOU STARTED OUT WITH THE
POINT THAT HE COULDN'T BE TRIED
FOR MURDER WHEN ALL HE NEEDED TO
DO WAS BRING A CIVIL SUIT TO
ENFORCE A CONTRACT.
SPEAKER:  YES, YOUR HONOR.
[LAUGHTER].  NO.  I THINK BOTH
THINGS ARE TRUE.  I THINK THAT
IT'S TOTALLY INAPPROPRIATE THAT
ANY REQUEST OF A COURT COULD BE
A CRIMINAL ACT.  SO FOR THAT
REASON, I DON'T THINK IT'S
POSSIBLE TO CONVICT HIM UNDER
THE ALIEN ACT.  I DON'T THINK
THERE IS ANY WAY THAT THIS COULD
BE ATTEMPTED MURDER AND
SEPARATELY AND NOT IN A
CONSISTENT POINT, HE DIDN'T DO
ANYTHING.  DURING THE SCENE HE
HAD A KNIFE.  AND HE SAID SOME
WORDS THAT HE MAY
REGRET.  AND NOTHING ELSE
HAPPENED.
SPEAKER:  BUT THE QUESTION OF
MOTIVE IS IMPORTANT TO US.  IT'S
IMPORTANT IN TERMS OF THINKING
WHAT SHYLOCK DID AND HOW WE
SHOULD RULE HERE.  I MEAN, ONE
MOTIVE IS REVENGE WHICH
OBVIOUSLY WOULD BE CAUGHT UP
WITH THE MURDER AND YOU MAKE AN
ARGUMENT IN YOUR BRIEF THAT YOU
JUST MENTIONED A MINUTE AGO THAT
SHYLOCK WAS IN FACT IN A SENSE,
REBELLING THROUGH THIS
CONTRACT.
I'M NOT SURE I REALLY UNDERSTAND
WHAT YOU MEAN BY THAT.  MAYBE
CAN YOU ELABORATE A LITTLE BIT
ON THAT FOR US.  WHAT DO YOU
MEAN?  WHAT WAS SHYLOCK DOING
HERE IF IT WASN'T REVENGE?
SPEAKER:  YES, YOUR HONOR.  THE
INTENT TO ENFORCE THE PENALTY
PROVISION WAS A REBELLION
AGAINST THE VENETIAN LAWS THAT
TREATED HIM SO DIFFERENTLY AND
THIS WAS THE ONE AREA WHERE HE
WAS ABLE TO SORT OF SET THE
TERMS OF HIS LIFE.  AND THE
OTHER PART OF THIS IS DURING THE
PROCEEDING, WHAT SHYLOCK POINTS
OUT ABOUT ANTONIO AND THE OTHER
VENETIAN MERCHANTS IS THE
INCREDIBLE HYPOCRISY.  VENETIAN
CAPITALISM, THERE IS TRADE IN
MANY THINGS.  BUT ONE OF THE
ASPECTS OF TRADE WAS SLAVERY.
AND SO IT SEEMS VERY CRITICAL
AND IMPROPER THAT MERCHANTS LIKE
ANTONIO SHOULD BE ABLE TO GROW
WEALTHY SELLING PEOPLE AGAINST
THEIR WILL AND MY CLIENT SHOULD
NOT BE ABLE TO RECOVER THE
PENALTY PROVISION, EVEN THOUGH
THERE IS, YOU KNOW, THERE IS A
PHYSICAL COMPONENT TO IT.
SPEAKER:  AS I UNDERSTAND IT, IT
WAS A CONTRACT.  THEY ACTUALLY
MADE A LEGAL CONTRACT, EVEN
THOUGH SHYLOCK SAID SOMETHING
ABOUT BEING A MARRIED JOKE OR
SOMETHING, WHICH MEANT THAT THEY
FULLY
EXPECTED THE MONEY WOULD BE
RETURNED ON TIME.  AND THEN HE
PERCENT PERSEVERED TO THE POWER
OF FLESH AND THEN HE FINDS OUT
ABOUT THE BLOOD, YOU KNOW, DO
YOU THINK IT COULD BE DONE IN
SOME OTHER WAY SO THAT ANTONIO
WOULD NOT DIE?  WHAT DID YOU
FIND OUT IN YOUR
INVESTIGATION OF THIS CASE?  OF
WHAT HE HAD IN MIND.
SPEAKER:  SHYLOCK DID NOT INTEND
TO MURDER ANTONIO.  IT WAS A
POUND OF FLESH.  IT WAS NOT A
DAGGER IN THE HEART OR ANYTHING
LIKE THAT.
SPEAKER:  HE WANTED IT NEAR THE
HEART?
SPEAKER:  YEAH, HE WANTED IT
NEAR THE HEART, BUT THE COURT
DOESN'T KNOW ANY MORE THAN I DO
IF HE HAD BEEN GRANTED THAT.  IF
PORSHA HAD GRANTED HIM THAT
RIGHT AND DIDN'T FORCE THAT
SPECIFIC PERFORMANCE, HE MIGHT
HAVE DROPPED THE KNIFE AND ASKED
FOR THE MONEY INSTEAD.  THERE
IS NO WAY TO KNOW AT THIS POINT.
SPEAKER:  ANY CASE, WE HAVE
SETTLED THE POUND OF FLESH IS
OUT OF THE CASE NOW.  IT'S JUST
A MATTER OF MONEY.
SPEAKER:  YES, YOUR HONOR.
WE'RE NOT SEEKING THE POUND OF
FLESH.  AND AFTER ALL THIS TIME
WE'RE NOT COMING TO HAVE THAT BE
ENFORCED.
SPEAKER:  BUT MR. KLOTZ IF
YOU'RE JUST FOCUSING ON THE
CIVIL ACTION AND NOT SEEKING THE
POUND OF FLESH, YOU'RE SEEKING
THE REPAYMENT OF THE MONEY PLUS
INTEREST, ISN'T THIS A CLAIM
NOT RAISED BELOW?  THIS ISN'T
APPELLATE COURT.  DID YOU RAISE
THIS CLAIM BELOW?
[LAUGHTER].
SPEAKER:  THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION YOUR HONOR.
SPEAKER:  THANK YOU.
SPEAKER:  I TAKE IT YOU'RE
SEEKING A SUBSTITUTIONAL REMEDY
SINCE THE ONE YOU ASKED FOR, THE
LAW DOES NOT PERMIT.
SPEAKER:  WELL, WHAT I THINK
YOUR HONOR IS -- I MEAN THE
PROCEEDING IS OBVIOUSLY TOTAL
IMPROPER WITH PORSHA ACTING AS
THE JUDGE.  THE OTHER MAIN POINT
THAT WE HAVEN'T DISCUSSED YET
BUT IS DISCUSSED IN THE BRIEF IS
THE INCREDIBLE DURESS FROM MY
CLIENT DURING THE PROCEEDING.
FIRST PORSHA SAYS YOU KNOW, YOU
CAN GET THE POUND OF FLESH AND
YOU DON'T GET BLOOD AND DON'T
GET ANY MORE OR LESS THAN THAT.
AND SHYLOCK HAS BEEN ASKED FOR
THE MONEY AND BEEN TOLD NO AND
PORSHA THEN SAID HE VIOLATED THE
ACT SUPPOSEDLY FOR MAKING THE
REQUEST TO COURT.  AND THEN
SHYLOCK WAS FORCED TO CONVERT TO
CHRISTIANITY AND THE DUKE SAID
VERY
CLEARLY, IF HE DIDN'T DO THAT,
HE WOULD BE EXECUTED.  TO THE
EXTENT THAT THERE IS A LABOR
ARGUMENT, I THINK
WE CAN LET THAT SLIDE.  BUT WE
ASK -- WE'RE ASKING THIS COURT
-- TO FOLLOW-UP ON YOUR POINT,
THE CIVIL REMEDIES, WE'RE ASKING
TO HAVE MY CLIENT'S NAME
CLEARED AFTER ALL OF THIS TIME.
THERE IS NOTHING THAT, YOU
KNOW, NOTHING THAT WE CAN DO
ABOUT THIS IMPROPER VERDICT,
OTHER THAN TO, YOU KNOW,
COMPLETELY NULLIFY HIM.
SPEAKER:  YOU MADE A COMMENT
ABOUT THE ALIEN ACT.  ARE YOU
ARGUING THAT THE ALIEN ACT IN
AND OF ITSELF, MAYBE YOU CAN
EXPLAIN WHY THAT IS, ARE YOU
ARGUING THAT THAT IS SOMEHOW
NOT LEGITIMATE OR SOMEHOW
APPLIED WRONG TO SHYLOCK?
SPEAKER:  IT'S TOTALLY
LEGITIMATE.  FOR A CERTAIN GROUP
OF PEOPLE, IT PROTECTS VENETIAN
CITIZENS IN A WAY THAT
NON-CITIZENS WOULD BE PROTECTED.
IF SOMEONE HAD MADE AN ATTEMPT
TO MURDER MY CLIENT SHYLOCK,
THAT WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN IN
VIOLATION AND NOTHING WOULD HAVE
HAPPENED WHAT SO EVER.  AND
JUST TO GIVE AN EXAMPLE FROM OUR
CASE, THE DUKE SAYING, SHYLOCK,
IF YOU DON'T CONVERT TO
CHRISTIANITY, I'M GOING TO
EXECUTE YOU, YOU KNOW, THAT IS
CONCERNING.
SPEAKER:  BUT DID YOU CONSIDER
THAT THE ONLY CHANCE THAT
SHYLOCK HAD WAS SALVATION, SO
FAR FROM BEING A PENALTY, IT WAS
A TREMENDOUS ADVANTAGE TO
SHYLOCK TO BE CONVERTED TO A
CHRISTIAN, SO THEN HIS
SOUL CAN BE SAVED.  [LAUGHTER].
SPEAKER:  YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
CORRECT, YOUR HONOR.  I THINK
THAT IS WHAT HE BELIEVES.
SPEAKER:  IN OTHER WORDS THE
DUKE WAS ACTING MERCIFULLY AND
SHYLOCK WHO PORSHA BEGGED TO
ACT MERCIFULLY NEVER DID.
SHYLOCK REFUSED, UP UNTIL THE
LAST MINUTE, TO RENOUNCE THE
POUND OF FLESH.
SPEAKER:  WE CAN'T DISPUTE, YOUR
HONOR, THAT SHYLOCK DIDN'T ACT
WITH ALL OF THE MERCY THAT HE
COULD HAVE IN THIS PROCEEDING.
BUT I BELIEVE THAT THE FACTORS
THAT WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT, YOU
KNOW, THE TREATMENT THAT HE
EXPERIENCED, HIS VIEW THAT IF HE
DOESN'T HAVE HIS RIGHTS UNDER
THE CONTRACT, WHAT RIGHTS DOES
HE HAVE?  HE IS ALREADY TREATED
IN THIS TOTALLY UNFAIR AND
DESPERATE WAY.  AND YOU KNOW,
THE AUDACITY OF ANTONIO TO ACT
AS IF THIS PENALTY PROVISION
THAT THEY HAD AGREED UPON AND
NEGOTIATED AND REDUCED TO
WRITING WAS SOMEHOW AN OUTRAGE
AND SHYLOCK WAS BEYOND THE PAIL
TRYING TO ENFORCE THE TERMS THAT
THEY AGREED ON.
SPEAKER:  DID YOU SAY HE DID NOT
VIOLATE THE ALIEN RULE BECAUSE
HE DIDN'T ACTUALLY PERFORM
ANYTHING AGAINST ANTONIO, EVEN
THOUGH HE MAY HAVE WANTED TO?
SPEAKER:  THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT,
YOUR HONOR.
SPEAKER:  OKAY.  YOUR TIME IS
ALMOST UP.  DO YOU WANT TO JUST
QUICKLY SUM UP?
SPEAKER:  YES, YOUR HONOR TO
REITERATE, WE ASK THE COURT TO,
ONCE AND FOR ALL, VACATE THE
DECISION BELOW WITHOUT THE NEED
FOR RETRIAL FOR MY CLIENT AND
THE 3 THOUSAND IN DUCKETS BE
RETURNED IN FULL AND HE BE
AWARDED INTEREST IN THIS MONEY
AND THE COURT AWARDS FURTHER
RELIEF THAT YOU THINK IS
APPROPRIATE, PARTICULARLY IN
LIGHT THAT HE AND OTHER JEWISH
RESIDENTS IN VENICE SUFFERED.
SPEAKER:  THANK YOU,
COUNSEL.
SPEAKER:  THANK YOU.
[APPLAUSE].
SPEAKER:  WE WILL NOW HEAR FROM
COUNSEL FOR THE MERCHANT OF
VENICE, ANTONIO AND THE REPUBLIC
OF VENICE.
SPEAKER:  THANK YOU YOUR HONOR.
I WANT TO BEGIN BY REJECTING THE
TRANSPARENTLY FALSE NARRATIVE
THAT WE HAVE BEEN PRESENTED WITH
HERE.  THE NOTION THAT SHYLOCK
WAS ENGAGED SIMPLY IN A NOBLE
AND HONORABLE PROTEST OF WHAT HE
THOUGHT TO BE THE DEFICIENCIES
AND UNFAIRNESS OF VENETIAN LAW.
THAT IS
SIMPLY NOT TRUE.  AND NEVER
UNTIL THIS APPEAL HAVE WE HEARD
THAT TRUE.  IF WE LOOK AT THE
CASE, AGAIN AND AGAIN AND AGAIN,
IT SHOWS THAT SHYLOCK ENTERED
INTO A PREMEDITATED
AND DECEITFUL COURSE OF ACTION
IN ORDER TO LURE ANTONIO INTO
HEALING A BOND THAT WOULD BE THE
MEANS OF HIS OWN DESTRUCTION
AND THERE ARE FOUR CRITICAL
ELEMENTS IN THIS SCHEME THAT ARE
UNDISPUTED IN THE RECORD OF THE
CASE.  FIRST THROUGHOUT SHYLOCK
ADMITTED TO HIS MOTIVES, EVEN
BEFORE HE NEGOTIATED THE PENALTY
BOND, HE WAS OVER HER TO SAY
QUOTE, SPEAKING OF ANTONIO, I
HATE HIM.  FOR HE IS A
CHRISTIAN.  IF I CAN CATCH HIM
ONCE ON THE HIP, I WILL FEED FAT
THE ANCIENT GRUDGE I BEAR HIM.
HIMSELF A FEW MINUTES AGO SAY
THAT THE POUND OF FLESH WILL BE
ABLE TO STATE DISH WITH ALL.
AND FURTHER USE THAT POUND OF
FLESH TO FEED HIS REVENGE.
OTHER EVIDENCE OF THE MOTIVE OF
REVENGE AND HATRED THROUGHOUT
THE RECORD OF THIS CASE.  BUT IF
THERE ARE ANY DOUBTS, IT WOULD
HAVE BEEN SATISFIED WHEN AT HIS
TRIAL IN RESPONSE TO QUESTIONS
BY THE DUKE, HE EXPLAINED THAT
HIS MOTIVE WAS A QUOTE LOGIC
HATE AND UNCERTAIN LOATHING.
END QUOTE.
SPEAKER:  COUNSEL, BEFORE WE GET
INTO YOUR DISCUSSION OF THE
MERITS OF A CRIMINAL
PROSECUTION, I THINK YOU
CONCEDED AT THE OUTSET THAT THAT
TURN OF THE PROCEEDING FROM A
CIVIL SUIT TO ENFORCE A
CONTRACT, INTO A CRIMINAL CASE,
WAS HIGHLY INAPPROPRIATE.  DID
YOU NOT MAKE THAT CONCESSION IN
YOUR BRIEF?
SPEAKER:  I THINK WE HAVE TWO
RESPONSES TO THAT, YOUR HONOR.
THE FIRST IS THAT ANTONIO WAS
PERMITTED TO USE AS A
COUNTERCLAIM, OR AS A DEFENSE.
ANY LAW THAT WOULD BE AVAILABLE.
SPEAKER:  CAN YOU BRING IN A
CIVIL CASE?  A CRIMINAL
PROSECUTION AS A
COUNTERCLAIM?
SPEAKER:  ABSOLUTELY.
SPEAKER:  ABSOLUTELY.  UNDER THE
LAW OF VENICE AT THAT TIME,
THIS KIND OF PLEADING IS
RECOGNIZED.
AS WE ARGUE IN THE BRIEF YOUR
HONOR, WE HAVE AN ADDITIONAL
POINT.  AND THAT IS, WE DO AGREE
ON ONE POINT WITH SHYLOCK.  AND
THAT IS THAT THE PROCEDURES
WERE FLAWED BY REASON OF
PORSHA'S MISREPRESENTATION AND
MASCERADE AND FOR THIS REASON WE
ASK THE COURT TO CONSIDER THIS
CASE DE NOVA.
SPEAKER:  WELL,
JUDGE REMINDED US THAT THIS IS
A COURT OF
VIEW.
NOT FIRST VIEW.  WE WOULD BE
LOOK AT A CASE.  BUT WE ARE AN
APPELLANT FOR THEM.  SO WE HAVE
NO AUTHORITY TO HEAR WITNESSES.
AND WE JUDGE THE CASE
ACCORDING TO THE LAW.  SO I
DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW YOU CAN ASK
THIS COURT TO SERVE AS A FIRST
INSTANCE.  DE NOVO COURT.
SPEAKER:  EVEN THIS COURT SHOULD
DECLINE TO CONSIDER THE
CASE ENTIRELY NEW, THE
OPPORTUNITY OF REPRESENTATION BY
VARIABLE COUNSEL AND THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE ALL OF HIS
ARGUMENTS ENSURES THAT SHYLOCK
NOW HAS THE RIGHT TO ARGUE
AGAINST THE APPLICATION OF THE
ALIEN LAW TO HIM.
SPEAKER:  AND WITH THE
PROCEEDING, IS IMPROPER.  THEN I
SUPPOSE THE APPELLATE COURT
SHOULD JUST DISMISS IT, AND IF
IT DISMISSES THE CASE, THEN
WHERE ARE WE?
SPEAKER:  WELL IF THIS COURT
SIMPLY DISMISSES THE CASE, THEN
I THINK IT WOULD PUT ANTONIO AND
THE DUKE OF VENICE IN THE
POSITION THAT THEY WOULD WANT TO
BE IN.  BECAUSE IT WOULD DENY
ANY AND ALL RELIEF TO SHYLOCK.
SPEAKER:  BUT YOU ARE NOT URGING
US TO DO THAT BECAUSE YOU
RECOGNIZE THAT HE DID NOT GET A
FAIR TRIAL, IS THAT IT?
SPEAKER:  WE GRANT THAT THE
PROCEDURES WERE NOT FAIR
PROCEDURES.  YES.
SPEAKER:  LET ME GO TO WHAT
SEEMS TO BE YOUR PRINCIPLE
ARGUMENT, THAT THIS WAS AN ACT
OF VENGINCE
ON SHYLOCK'S PART.
BUT SHYLOCK, WHEN THE
TRANSACTION TOOK PLACE, CALLED
IT A MERRY SPORT.  A MERRY BOND.
AND REALLY THE ASPECT OF YOUR
POSITION THAT IT'S ALL
VENE NVENENGANCE AND AT THE
TIME, WAS ABLE TO THINK THAT
RICH MERCHANT OF VENICE WOULD BE
ABLE TO PAY HIM.  HE HAD NO
IDEA OF THE PROPOSED TRAGEDY AT
SEA.  HE EXPECTED, AS ANTONIO
DID, THAT ANTONIO WOULD BE --
HIS WEALTH WOULD BE INCREASED,
WELL WITHIN THE TIME OF THE
LOAN.
SPEAKER:  I THINK THE RECORD
SHOWS THAT FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING, SHYLOCK WAS SCHEMING
TO TRAP ANTONIO.  HE SAID TO
ANTONIO AT THE TIME THEY WERE
DISCUSSING THE BOND, HE WAS
OFFERING THE LOAN FOR
RECONCILIATION AND FRIENDSHIP.
HE SAID QUOTE I WOULD BE FRIENDS
WITH YOU AND HAVE YOUR LOVE TO
ANTONIO.  AS YOU POINT
OUT, HE REFERRED TO THE BOND AS
A SPORT.
AND QUICKLY ADDED IT WAS
WORTHLESS.  NOBODY COULD EXPECT
HIM TO EVER CLAIM THE BOND
BECAUSE A POUND OF MAN'S FLESH
TAKEN FROM A MAN IS NOT
ESTIMATABLE, PROFITABLE EITHER
FROM GOATS.
SPEAKER:  BUT HOW -- WHAT BASES
DID SHYLOCK HAVE TO
EVEN SUSPECT THAT THIS QUESTION
WOULD ARRIVE AND THAT ANTONIO
WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO REPAY HIM?
ANTONIO WAS A RICH MERCHANT?
THERE WERE NO STORMS AT SEA.
WHY WOULD YOU ATTRIBUTE TO
SHYLOCK SUCH A MOTIVE OF
VENGEANCE WHEN SHYLOCK HAD EVERY
REASON IN THE WORLD TO EXPECT
THAT WITHIN THE THREE MONTH'S
TIME HE WOULD BE REPAID?
SPEAKER:
HE WAS LAYING A
TRAP.
HE UNDERSTOOD THAT HE WOULD
PROBABLY BE REPAID.  AND IF HE
WERE NOT, THIS WOULD BE HIS
OPPORTUNITY FINALLY TO HAVE THE
REVENGE THAT HE FOUGHT SO
DEARLY.  THERE IS A LITTLE
NOTICED FACT THAT IS SO
INTERESTING IN THIS CASE AND
THAT IS WHEN HE FIRST HEARD
ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A
PENALTY BOND FROM ANTONIO,
SHYLOCK DIDN'T HAVE THE MONEY.
HE DIDN'T HAVE THE MONEY.  WHAT
DID HE DO?  HE WENT TO HIS MONEY
LENDER FRIEND AND BORROWED THE
MONEY TO LEND IN ORDER TO GET
THE PENALTY BOND.  IN OTHER
WORDS, HE
WAS WILLING TO PAY INTEREST TO
TUBAL AND LOAN FREE OF CHARGE,
FREE OF CHARGE.  AND THAT WAS TO
SET UP THE TRAP.
AND IT SHOWS THROUGHOUT FROM THE
VERY BEGINNING TO THE VERY END,
EVEN THOUGH HE RECOGNIZED THAT
HE WOULD PROBABLY BE REPAID, THE
TRAP COULD BE SET AND
HE WOULD HAVE HIS REVENGE.
SPEAKER:  ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
SHYLOCK SAID A FEW TIMES.  I
CRAVE THE
LAW.  NOBODY TOLD HIM ABOUT THE
ALIEN ACT.  SO OBVIOUS
OPPORTUNITY TO RETHINK THE CASE
IN LIGHT OF THE LAW.  BUT
SHYLOCK CRAVED THE LAW, ONCE HE
SAW WHAT THE LAW IS.  AND HOW
THE FLESH IS OFF THE TABLE.
SPEAKER:  THE POUND OF FLESH IS
NOT A VALID PENALTY BOND UNDER
VENETIAN LAW.  VENETIAN LAW,
IT'S TRUE, ENFORCED COMMERCIAL
CURVES.  THE PENALTY BOND HERE
IS NOT A COMMERCIAL TERM.  IN
FACT SHYLOCK HIMSELF ADMITTED
MANY TIMES IT WAS NOT A
COMMERCIAL TERM WHEN HE SAID
THAT HE WOULD GLADLY GIVE UP
REPAYMENT OF 20 TIMES THE LOAN,
IN ORDER TO ENFORCE
THE PENALTY BOND.
SPEAKER:  BUT WHAT ABOUT THE
STATE OF MIND OF YOUR CLIENT
ANTONIO?  WHY DID HE AGREE TO
THIS SO QUICKLY?
SPEAKER:  AND JUST TO FOLLOW-UP
ON THAT, I HAVE A PROBLEM WITH
THAT AS WELL.  IT'S NOT HARD FOR
ME TO UNDERSTAND WHY SHYLOCK
WOULD WANT THIS BOND, WHETHER WE
THINK IT WAS REVENGE OR WHETHER
WE THINK IT WAS POLITICAL
EXPRESSION OF SOME SORT.  BUT
WHY WOULD ANTONIO AGREE TO BE
BOUND BY THIS BOND?  WHY WOULD
HE AGREE TO GIVE UP A POUND OF
HIS OWN FLESH JUST TO GET MONEY
FOR BESANIO AND WHAT I AM
THINKING HERE IS REALLY, IS IT
POSSIBLE THAT ANTONIO WAS THE
ONE LAYING THE TRAP FOR SHYLOCK,
BECAUSE ANTONIO KNEW THAT
SHYLOCK WOULD BE
HIT WITH THE ALIEN ACT.
SPEAKER:  WELL THERE IS NO
EVIDENCE IN THE RECORD TO
SUGGEST.
SPEAKER:  THERE MAY NOT BE
REFERENCE IN THE RECORD TO THAT.
BUT I AM JUST SPECULATING.
SPEAKER:  MAY I INTERJECT THAT
THERE ARE MULTIPLE CLUES IN THE
RECORD.  WHEN WE FIRST MEET
ANTONIO, HE SAYS ENSUED.  I KNOW
NOT
WHY.  I AM SAD.  HE LATER SAYS
I AM TAINTED WHETHER OF THE
FLESH, TAINTED OR DEATH.  THIS
IS A VERY SAD MAN WHO
IS LONGING FOR
DEATH.
SPEAKER:  I THINK HE SNAPPED OUT
OF THE QUESTION.  TO ANSWER THE
QUESTION, ANTONIO WAS FULL AND
TAKEN IN BY THE RECONCILIATION
AND FRIENDSHIP THAT HE THOUGHT
WAS BEING OFFERED BY SHYLOCK.
AND IN FACT, ANTONIO, AS HE WAS
GOING AND SEALING THE BOND SAID
QUOTE, THERE IS MUCH KINDNESS IN
THE JEW, END QUOTE.  AND I HAVE
TO SAY, ALTHOUGH HE IS MY
CLIENT, THAT ANTONIO WAS EASY
PREY IN ANOTHER SENSE.  HE
PROFOUNDLY EX
TRAVAGENTLY HAD A PROUD SENSE OF
HONOR.  AND SHYLOCK, COMING AS
HE WAS, PREYED ON THIS CHARACTER
DEFECT OF ANTONIO AND HE DID SO
IN THE FOLLOWING WAY.  HE
RECOGNIZED THAT IF IT EVER CAME
TIME TO ENFORCE THE PENALTY
BOND, ANTONIO WOULD BE TOO PROUD
TO DISHONOR IT.  AND THAT IN
OTHER WORDS, HE WOULD ADMIT IT.
AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
HAPPENED.
ANTONIO DIDN'T HIRE A LAWYER.
ANTONIO OFFERED NO DEFENSE.
ANTONIO CONFESSED THE BOND AND
OFFERED HIMSELF UP TO BE KILLED.
AND THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT
SHYLOCK'S SCHEME WAS.  HE KNEW
THAT ANTONIO'S SCHEME WOULD NOT
EXIST AND THERE WOULD BE NO
COURT PROCEEDING STANDING
BETWEEN HIMSELF
AND HIS OPPORTUNITY TO KILL
ANTONIO AND THAT'S WHY THE
ARGUMENT THAT THERE IS AN INNER
SESSION OF THE COURT PROCEEDING
WOULD WORK.
BECAUSE SHYLOCK TAKING ADVANTAGE
OF HIS CHARACTER FLAW KNEW THAT
THERE WOULD BE NO MEANINGFUL
ADDITIONAL PROTECTION OF
ANTONIO.
SPEAKER:  SPEAKING OF BEING
TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF, SHYLOCK, IN
A WAY, NEVER GOT DUE PROCESS.
NEVER HAD ANYBODY TO ADVISE HIM
OF WHAT THE CONSEQUENCES WOULD
BE.  OR WHAT THE JOURNEY THROUGH
THE LAW WOULD MEAN FOR HIM.  IS
IT NOT AMAZING TO YOU THAT YOU
TAKE A CIVIL CASE AND IT ENDS UP
BEING A CRIMINAL CASE?  SHOULD
HE NOT HAVE BEEN GIVEN DUE
PROCESS ALONG
THE WAY.
SPEAKER:  LET'S TAKE IT IN
STEPS.  IN THE NEGOTIATION IN
THE PENALTY BOND,
I THINK THAT SHYLOCK IS A VERY
EXPERIENCED MONEY LENDER AND
KNOWLEDGEABLE ABOUT THE
APPLICABLE
LAW.  AND IT SHOWS
THAT REGARDLESS OF THE
CRITICISM WE HAVE IN THE LAW,
COURT PROCEEDINGS WERE OPEN TO
JEWS IN VENICE AND THE
PROTECTION OF THE LAWS WERE
APPLICABLE TO
THEM.  YOU ARE RIGHT THAT WHEN
THEY GOT TO COURT, THE SHARADE,
MASCERADE DID DENY HIM DUE
PROCESS.  AND WE ENTIRELY AGREE
WITH THAT.  WE THINK, HOWEVER,
THOUGH, THE BASIS OF THE RECORD
AND THE DEVASTATING ADMISSIONS
REPEATEDLY MADE
BY SHYLOCK, THAT HE PROPERLY
STANDS CONVICTED OF THE OFFENSE
AT WHICH HE WAS FOUND GUILTY.
SPEAKER:  HOW DOES THE ALIEN ACT
COME INTO THE PICTURE?  YOU
JUST SAID THAT ANTONIO WASN'T
PUTTING UP ANY DEFENSE.  HE
CERTAINLY DIDN'T RAISE THE ALIEN
ACT.  IT WAS THIS SHAM LAWYER
JUDGE PORSHA WHO BROUGHT THAT.
SPEAKER:  WELL, OUR BRIEF POINTS
OUT THAT THE INTERVENTION OF
PORSHA INDEED SAVED THE LIFE OF
ANTONIO AND INDEED SAVED THE
LIFE OF SHYLOCK. AND SAVED
SHYLOCK BECAUSE SHYLOCK WAS
READY, WILLING AND ABLE TO KILL
ANTONIO.  THE NOTION THAT
ANTONIO WOULD HAVE BEEN SPARED
BY SHYLOCK IS ABSOLUTELY CRAZY.
THE RECORD SHOWS
SHYLOCK WAS EARNESTLY
SHARPENING HIS LIFE IN THE
COURT.  AND SHYLOCK HAD A
BALANCE SCALE, IN ORDER TO
MEASURE THE POUND OF FLESH.  DO
IT.  AND IT WAS ONLY PORSHA THAT
SAVED ANTONIO AND SHYLOCK
HIMSELF.
SPEAKER:  COUNSEL, I WOULD LIKE
TO ASK A QUESTION HERE.  I THINK
WE WOULD ALL AGREE THAT THE
RECORD IS BEAUTIFULLY WRITTEN.
LEAST OF THE COURT PROCEEDINGS.
AND I BELIEVE THAT YOU ARE
ASKING US TO DRAW A LOT OF
INFERENCES FROM THE RECORD.
WHAT ABOUT THIS INFERENCE THAT
SHYLOCK NEVER BELIEVED THAT THE
COURT WOULD ALLOW HIM TO EXACT
HIS FLESH.  HE DOES SEEM
SURPRISED IN THE COURT
PROCEEDING WHEN PORSHA SAYS,
YOU'RE RIGHT.  YOU MAY ENFORCE
THE PENALTY BOND AND PRAISES HER
AND SOUNDS VERY SURPRISED.  WHY
ISN'T IT A REASONABLE INFERENCE
AS YOU HAVE HAVE US DRAW, THAT
HE WAS WILLING TO PUT THE KNIFE
TO ENTER HIS HEART.  WHY ISN'T
IT JUST AS EQUALLY VALID
INFERENCE THAT HE NEVER THOUGHT
THAT THE COURT WOULD ALLOW HIM
TO EXACT THIS MEASURE -- ENFORCE
THE PENALTY BOND LITERALLY?
SPEAKER:  WELL, WITH ALL
RESPECT, WE DON'T THINK THERE IS
ANY QUESTION OF INFERENCE.
BECAUSE WE HAVE THE MAN'S WORDS.
AGAIN AND AGAIN AND AGAIN.
THOSE WORDS, EVENTS, NOTHING
OTHER THAN AN INTENT TO EXECUTE
ANTONIO TO HAVE REVENGE AND TO
REALIZE THE LONG-STANDING OBJECT
OF HIS HATRED.  THAT IS THE
KILLING EVENT.
SPEAKER:  THAT'S ANOTHER
INFERENCE.  JUST AS GINSBURG
POINTED OUT.  SHYLOCK SAID ON
SEVERAL OCCASIONS, THIS IS A
MARRIED BOND.  THIS IS NOTHING
TO BE WORRIED ABOUT.  AND HE
DOES APPEAR SURPRISED WHEN
PORSHA SAYS, YOU'RE RIGHT.  YOU
WIN.  WHY IS THIS NOT A PROPER
INFERENCE FOR US TO DRAW THAT HE
MIGHT HAVE, SINCE YOU WANT US
TO DRAW SOME INFERENCES FROM THE
RECORD, WHY ISN'T IT
APPROPRIATE TO DRAW THAT
INFERENCE AS WELL?
SPEAKER:  AS I READ THE RECORD,
BEAUTIFULLY WRITTEN AS IT IS, I
WOULD CHARACTERIZE SHYLOCK'S
REACTION NOT AS
SURPRISED.  BUT AS EXULTANT
DELIGHT.
SPEAKER:  COUNSEL, COUNSEL, YOUR
TIME IS ABOUT TO RUN OUT.  SO
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO CONCLUDE.
SPEAKER:  THANK YOU.  FOR THE
REASONS ARGUED IN OUR BRIEF AND
THE ARGUMENTS THAT I WOULD HAVE
MADE, IF I DID NOT HAVE SO MANY
GOOD QUESTIONS, WE BELIEVE, WE
BELIEVE THAT THE JUDGMENT WAS
CORRECT, AND THAT THIS COURT
SHOULD ARRIVE AT THE SAME
JUDGMENT ON ITS OWN INITIATIVE.
THANK YOU.
SPEAKER:  INCLUDING CONVERSION.
SPEAKER:  ABSOLUTELY INCLUDING
CONVERSION.  THAT'S TO SAVE THE
ETERNAL SOUL OF SHYLOCK.
[APPLAUSE].
SPEAKER:  WE WILL NOW HEAR FROM
PORSHA'S COUNSEL.
SPEAKER:  JUSTICE
GINSBURG AND
COURT, I'M TERESA
MIGUEL-STEARNS.  I'M COUNSEL FOR
PORSHA.  YEARS AGO, PORSHA
PROVIDED TO THE COUNSEL OF
VENICE.  IN A DISPUTE BETWEEN
SHYLOCK, AND CO-APELLEE ANTONIO,
THIS ALMOST TURNED DEADLY.
PORSHA'S SKILLFUL NAVIGATION OF
VENETIAN LAW SAVED BOTH MENS'
LIVES.  AS A DIRECT RESULT AND
HER ROLE IN THIS SHYLOCK ANTONIO
DISPUTE, PORSHA HAS SUFFERED
UNJUSTIFIED TARGETED ATTACKS TO
HER REPUTATION OVER THE COURSE
OF THE LAST 400 YEARS.  TODAY
PORSHA ASKED THAT SHE BE
DISCHARGED FROM THIS CASE AND
FROM ANY
FUTURE RELATED PROCEEDINGS.
YOUR HONOR, WE HAVE FIVE POINTS
TO OUR BRIEFS AND THE FIRST AND
FOREMOST IS THAT PORSHA IS THE
PRIMARY DEFENDEE IN THIS CASE
AND PORSHA'S ALLEGED
MISREPRESENTATIONS TO THE COURT
AND ALLEGED INTERESTS IN THE
OUTCOME OF THIS MATTER ARE
WITHOUT MERIT OR AT MOST,
HARMLESS ERROR.  AND I WILL TURN
TO THOSE MATTERS NOW.  FIRST
PORTIA IS THE DEFENDANT IN THIS
CASE.  AND COUNSEL IS WELL AWARE
THAT PORTIA'S ROLE WAS TO
LEGALLY PROVIDE THE ADVICE TO
DUKE OF VENICE.
SPEAKER:  PORTIA, ALTHOUGH SHE
WAS NOT A LAWYER, WE SEEM TO
RECOGNIZE THAT SHE KNEW
SOMETHING ABOUT THE LAW.  AND
SURELY SHE
WOULD HAVE KNOWN THAT FOR HER,
FOR PORTIA TO GIVE COUNSEL TO
THE DUKE.  AND FOR SHYLOCK TO
STAND THERE UNREPRESENTED, THAT
SHE WAS WILLING TO DO WHEN SHE
WAS A CIVIL PLAINTIFF.  BEING
PROSECUTED AND NO COUNSEL, APART
FROM YOUR CONFLICT OF INTEREST,
BEING MARRIED TO THE PRINCIPLE,
ISN'T THAT JUST OVERWHELMING?
SPEAKER:  YOUR HONOR RAISES
THREE POINTS.  AND I WOULD LIKE
TO ADDRESS THEM ALL.  FIRST,
THAT PORTIA WAS NOT LEARNED IN
THE LAW.  THE RECORD
DEMONSTRATES THAT PORTIA WAS
INDEED LEARNED IN THE LAW.  AND
IN 16TH CENTURY VENICE, ONE DID
NOT NEED A UNIVERSITY DIPLOMA OR
ANY --
SPEAKER:  CONCEDING THAT SHE WAS
LEARNING IN THE LAW.  MAYBE I
MISSPOKE OR MISUNDERSTOOD.  SHE
WAS IN THE LAW AND HAD TO BE IN
ORDER TO BE SUCH
A TRIXTER.  AND LEARNING FOR
THE REPUBLIC OF VENICE AND
ANTONIO.  AND SHYLOCK IS
STANDING THERE WITH NO ONE TO
REPRESENT HIM.  HE IS THE TARGET
OF A CRIMINAL PROSECUTION.
DOESN'T HE HAVE A RIGHT TO
COUNSEL?
SPEAKER:  YOUR HONOR, ON THE
ISSUE OF NOTICE, IT WAS SHYLOCK
WHO DRAGGED EVERYONE INTO COURT.
BASANIO, THE DUKE OF VENICE AND
OTHERS TRIED TO SETTLE THE CASE
PRIOR TO COMING TO COURT AND
SHYLOCK CRAVED HIS BOND AND
SHYLOCK WANTED THE POUND OF
FLESH AND BROUGHT EVERYONE INTO
COURT ON A CIVIL PROCEEDING.
THIS CASE NEVER TURNED INTO A
PROSECUTION.  PORTIA WAS NEVER A
PROSECUTOR AND THE ALIEN ACT
REMAINED A CASE.  AND AS SOON AS
PORTIA EXPLAINS TO THE DUKE OF
VENICE WHAT WAS INVOLVED IN THE
ALIEN STATUTE, BEFORE SHYLOCK
HAD TO UTTER A WORD, THE DUKE OF
VENICE SAID IMMEDIATELY, NO WE
ARE NOT GOING TO CONSIDER THIS
CAPITAL PUNISHMENT CASE.  WE
WILL KEEP IT AS A CIVIL CASE AND
SHYLOCK'S CASE IS THE ONLY
THING IN JEOPARDY.  SHYLOCK'S
LIFE OR FREEDOM WERE NEVER IN
JEOPARDY THROUGHOUT THE COURSE
OF THESE PROCEEDINGS.
SPEAKER:  BUT SHYLOCK NEVER KNEW
THAT THE LAW PUT HIM IN THAT
POSITION.  HE SAID, REPEATEDLY,
I CRAVE THE LAW.  HAD HE BEEN
COUNSELED, HE
WOULD HAVE KNOWN.
SPEAKER:  WITH DUE RESPECT, YOUR
HONOR, IGNORECE OF THE LAW IS
NO DEFENSE.
SPEAKER:  BUT HAVING NO COUNSEL.
SPEAKER:  MANY PEOPLE TRIED TO
CONVINCE SHYLOCK TO SETTLE THIS
CASE PRIOR TO IT BECOMING THE
CIVIL CASE REQUIRED BY THE ALIEN
ACT.  IN FACT, WHEN PORTIA
FIRST ENCOUNTERED THE COURTROOM.
SHE SAID WHO IS THE JEW AND
WHO IS THE MERCHANT.  SHE PLACED
BOTH PEOPLE, BOTH PARTICIPANTS
IN THIS TRIAL AT THE SAME LEVEL
AT THE EYES OF THE LAW.
SPEAKER:  WHO IS THE JEW?  NOT
WHO IS THE LENDER AND WHO IS THE
BORROWER?
SPEAKER:  RIGHT.  IT WAS --
THAT'S CORRECT, YOUR HONOR.
THIS IS WHAT THE TRANSCRIPT
SHOWS.
[APPLAUSE].
SPEAKER:  WE HAVE ANOTHER CLUE
TO PORTIA'S CHARACTER.  SO SHE
CALLS SHYLOCK A JEW.  BACK IN
BELMONT, SHE SAYS WE DON'T NEED
PEOPLE OF THAT DARK COMPLEXION.
THIS IS A WOMAN WHO ENTERTAINS
CERTAIN BIASES.
SPEAKER:  YOUR HONOR.  PORTIA
HAVE A VERY DISTINCT IDEA IN
BELMONT THAT SHE HAD WANTED TO
MARRY BESANIO.  THEY HAD LAID
EYES ON EACH OTHER IN THE PAST
AND HOPING THAT BESANIO WOULD BE
THE SUITOR WHO WOULD CORRECTLY
GUESS THE BOX, THE CASKET THAT
HER FATHER LAID OUT.
SPEAKER:  WAS PORTIA FREE TO
MARRY ANYONE SHE WANTED TO?
SPEAKER:  NO, SHE WAS NOT YOUR
HONOR.  PORTIA WAS A WEALTHY
ORPHAN WHOSE LIFE WAS DICTATED
BY HER LATE FATHER.  HER LATE
FATHER HAD PROVIDED FOR HER
EDUCATION, BUT HAD ALSO PROVIDED
THE METHOD FOR DICTATING WHO
HER HUSBAND WOULD BE.
SPEAKER:  AND
THAT MAY HAVE BEEN VERY
PATRIACHIAL.  BUT SPOKE ABOUT
BURNISH SKIN.  DID NOT REQUIRE
HER MARRIAGE FROM THE PEOPLE OF
MOROCCO.
SPEAKER:  THAT'S CORRECT YOUR
HONOR.
SPEAKER:  SO WE RECOGNIZE THAT
SHE HAS CERTAIN BIASES BASED ON
RACE AGAINST MOROCCO, AGAINST
SHYLOCK.
SPEAKER:  I WOULD PICK UP ON
THAT.  I SEE THAT, REALLY, AS A
CONFLICT OF INTEREST.  AS A
CONFLICT OF INTEREST, THE
UNCLEAN HANDS, YOU KNOW, BECAUSE
OF BESANIO AND SHE WAS TO GAIN
FROM THE SITUATION.
SPEAKER:  YES, REGARDING THE
CONFLICT OF INTEREST, PORTIA HAS
BOTH A FINANCIAL AND CONFLICT
OF INTEREST IN THIS CASE.  I
WILL ADDRESS BOTH.  FIRST THE
FINANCIAL CONFLICT OF INTEREST.
FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING, PORTIA SETTLED WITH
SHYLOCK, EVEN BEFORE SHE AND
BESANIO WERE MARRIED.  OFFERED
HER BUCKETS TO BESANIO TO SETTLE
THE CASE.
WHEN PORTIA FIRST WALKED INTO
COURT, SHE PLEADED WITH SHYLOCK
TO SETTLE THE CASE.
FINANCIALLY, TWO TIMES THE
AMOUNT, THREE TIMES THE AMOUNT,
TEN TIMES THE AMOUNTS OF HER
DUCKETS WERE OFFERED TO SHYLOCK.
WAS REFUSED.  SHE BROUGHT IN THE
QUALITY OF MERCY.  THE QUALITY
OF MERCY -- EXCUSE ME.  THE
QUALITY OF MERCY IS NOT
STRAINED.  IT'S DROPPED AS THE
GENTLE RAIN FROM HEAVEN BEYOND
THE PLACE BENEATH.
SPEAKER:  WHERE WAS HER MERCY?
SHE IS URGING SHYLOCK TO BE
MERCIFUL.  AND THEN SHE TURNS ON
HIM AND SAYS, I HAVE NO MERCY
FOR YOU.
SPEAKER:  I BELIEVE YOUR HONOR
IS REFERRING TO THE ALIEN ACT.
AND IT IS ACTUALLY PORTIA'S
MERCY WHICH SAVED BOTH
OF THEIR LIVES.  PORTIA IS
MERELY PROVIDING LEGAL ADVICE TO
THE DUKE OF VENICE.  WHEN
PORTIA REALIZES THAT SHE IS NOT
ABLE TO CONVINCE SHYLOCK TO
SETTLE THIS CASE, SHE GRANTS HIM
SPECIFIC PERFORMANCE ON THE
CONTRACT.
AND THAT IS TO TAKE THE POUND OF
FLESH.  BUT AT THE MOMENT THAT
SHYLOCK IS READY TO CARVE OUT A
POUND OF FLESH FROM ANTONIO'S
CHEST, PORTIA STOPS THE
PROCEEDING, STRICTLY INTERPRETS
THE CONTRACTS WITH THE REFERENCE
THAT WAS MADE EARLIER, IN THAT
A STRICT INTERPRETATION OF A
CONTRACT WOULD REQUIRE NO MORE,
NO LESS THAN A POUND OF FLESH.
AND NOT ANY OTHER MATTER.  NO
BLOOD.  NO OTHER MATTER.  NO
BONE.  NO ORGAN.  AT THAT POINT
SHE ALSO ADVISES THE DUKE THAT
SHYLOCK'S ACTIONS, SHYLOCK'S
ATTEMPT TO MURDER ANTONIO, WHICH
IS NOT IN DOUBT AT THIS POINT,
IS PUNISHABLE BY THE ALIEN
STATUTE.  THE ALIEN STATUTE --
SPEAKER:  YOU'RE TELLING US THEN
THAT THE CONTRACT, IT WAS
IMPOSSIBLE TO ENFORCE THE
CONTRACT.  SO THE POUND OF FLESH
HAS TO GO BY POSSIBILITY.
EVERYONE KNOWS THAT YOU CAN'T
TAKE FLESH WITHOUT BLOOD AS
WELL.  SO THEN WHAT WOULD HAPPEN
IF HE CAN'T GET THE REMEDY HE
IS DEMANDING, HE WOULD GET A
SUBSTITUTIONAL REMEDY AND WOULD
GET THE ORDINARY REMEDY FOR A
BREECH OF CONTRACT.  THAT IS, IN
THIS CASE, HIS MONEY BACK.
SPEAKER:  YOUR HONOR,
RESPECTFULLY, THIS CONTRACT WAS
ENFORCEABLE UNDER THE LAWS OF
VENICE.  THIS IS A COMMERCIAL
CONTRACT AND VENICE AS THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMERCIAL THAT IT
WAS, IT ENFORCES ALL CONTRACTS.
THE DUKE KNEW THIS.  ANTONIO
KNEW THIS AND EVEN SAID IT TO
HIS FRIENDS WHEN HE WAS GOING
INTO THE COURT.
SPEAKER:  BUT PORTIA IS CORRECT.
THE CONTRACT IS IMPOSSIBLE TO
ENFORCE.  YOU CAN'T TAKE FLESH
WITHOUT TAKING BLOOD.  THAT IS
NOT A POSSIBILITY.
SPEAKER:  YOUR HONOR, IT IS MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT WITH A
VERY HOT KNIFE, ONE CAN TAKE
FLESH WITHOUT BLOOD.
[LAUGHTER].
THIS CASE WAS TO MAKE SURE THAT
BOTH MEN WALKED OUT OF
THE COURTROOM ALIVE.  NOT ONE
ON A STRETCHER HAVING HIS CHEST
LED OUT AND CARVED ON HIS CHEST
AND NOT ANOTHER BEING HUNG OFF.
JUDGE.  NOT
A CONFLICTED ONE.
SPEAKER:  MS. MIGUEL-STEARNS, I
BELIEVE IT'S YOUR POSITION THAT
PORTIA DID NOT ENGAGE IN ANY
MISREPRESENTATION.  IS THAT
RIGHT?  YOU HAVE CERTAINLY
POINTED TO FACTS IN THE RECORD
THAT DO SUPPORT THE CONCLUSION
THAT SHE WAS VERY LEARNED IN THE
LAW.  BUT DIDN'T SHE ENGAGE IN
MISREPRESENTATION AND IF SO,
DOESN'T THAT TAINT THE
PROCEEDING SO THAT THE JUDGMENT
SHOULD BE SET ASIDE AND THERE
SHOULD BE A RETRIAL?
SPEAKER:  YOUR HONOR, THE ONLY
MISREPRESENTATION THAT PORTIA
MADE WAS DISGUISING HERSELF AS A
MAN.  THAT SHE WAS A WOMAN, HAD
ABSOLUTELY NO BEARING ON THE
OUTCOME OF THE CASE.  SHE WAS
LEGITIMATELY IN THE COURT HAVING
BEEN SENT THERE BY DR. BELARIO
TO PROVIDE LEGAL ADVICE TO THE
DUKE OF VENICE.  THE DUKE OF
VENICE DID NOT WANT TO ENFORCE
THE CONTRACT, EVEN THOUGH HE
FELT HE NEEDED TO, BECAUSE THE
LAWS OF VENICE NEED TO BE
STRICTLY ENFORCED IN ORDER TO
RETAIN IT, AS I MENTIONED.
SPEAKER:  BUT DID VELARIO KNOW
THAT PORTIA WAS MARRIED TO THE
PRINCIPLE IN THIS CASE?
SPEAKER:  YOUR HONOR, THE RECORD
IS NOT CLEAR ON THAT POINT.
HOWEVER, DR. VELARIO DID KNOW
THAT PORTIA WAS LEARNED IN THE
LAW AND WAS VERY CAPABLE OF
PROVIDING APPROPRIATE LEGAL
ADVICE TO THE DUKE.  DR. VELARIO
WROTE A LETTER PERSONALLY TO
THE DUKE AND ATTESTED PERSONALLY
TO THE DUKE, THAT HE AND PORTIA
HAD REVIEWED THE CASE AND
TURNED OVER MANY BOOKS TOGETHER
IN THIS MATTER AND DR. VELARIO
PROVIDED PORTIA WITH HIS
OPINION, WHICH ON TOP OF
PORTIA'S OWN LEGAL ADVICE,
DR. VELARIO KNEW HE WAS GOING
TO DESCRIBE HIMSELF AS A MAN AND
WAS GOING TO DO SO.  WAS A
TRUSTED LEGAL ADVISOR IN THE
DUKE OF VENICE AND WAS ILL THAT
DAY AND SAID PORTIA IN HIS
STEAD.  PORTIA HAD NO OTHER
INTEREST IN THIS MATTER OTHER
THAN TO SEE THE DISPUTE RESOLVED
AND SEE BOTH MEN ALIVE.
SPEAKER:  DID SHE NOT, AT SOME
POINT AT THE END, REJECT
SHYLOCK'S REQUEST FOR REPAYMENT?
SPEAKER:  YES, YOUR HONOR, SHE
DID.  AND THAT IS BECAUSE
MULTIPLE TIMES THROUGHOUT THE
COURSE OF THE PROCEEDINGS,
SHYLOCK HAD BEEN OFFERED TO
SETTLE THE CASE FINANCIALLY.  AT
SOME POINT THAT -- WHEN HE
FINALLY SAID NO, I
DEMAND MY BOND AND PORTIA
ADVISED THAT SPECIFIC
PERFORMANCE WOULD BE THE ONLY
REMEDY, AT THAT POINT ANY
NEGOTIATIONS ARE OFF THE TABLE.
VENICE IS A PLACE OF NO TAKE
BACKS.  YOU DON'T GET TWO
CHANCES IN VENICE.  ONCE THEY
PASS THE POINT OF SETTLING THE
CASE
AMMICIBLY AND FINANCIALLY, THAT
DOOR WAS CLOSED.  I GUESS I
CAN'T TAKE THAT POUND OF FLESH
AND LET'S GO BACK AND TIME AND I
WILL TAKE THE MONEY AND LEAVE.
THAT IS JUST NOT -- THAT IS JUST
NOT THE LAW IN VENICE.
SPEAKER:  PORTIA'S MOTIVATION TO
GET INVOLVED IN THIS, I DON'T
QUITE UNDERSTAND THE WAY YOU ARE
CHARACTERIZING IT.  SHE DECIDES
TO GET INVOLVED AFTER SHE HAS
HEARD THAT ANTONIO HAS LOST HIS
SHIFT.  SHE DECIDES THAT SHE
WANTS TO HELP ANTONIO BECAUSE
ANTONIO MUST BE A WONDERFUL
PERSON SINCE HE IS THE BEST
FRIEND OF HER HUSBAND.  AND AT
THAT POINT SHE DECIDES THAT SHE
IS GOING TO PLAY THIS TRICK.
DOESN'T THAT MOTIVATION IN AND
OF ITSELF, SHOW THAT SHE IS
DEEPLY CONFLICTED HERE IN TERMS
OF HER
INTEREST IN THE MATTER?
SPEAKER:  YOUR HONOR, AS I HAVE
MENTIONED, PORTIA IS NOT
CONFLICTED IN THIS CASE.  IT'S
TRUE THAT VESANIO AND ANTONIO
WERE FRIENDS.  BUT PORTIA HAD
NEVER MET ANTONIO.  PORTIA HAD
NEVER MET SHYLOCK.  PORTIA WAS
ONLY CONCERNED ABOUT PROVIDING
PROPER LEGAL ADVICE AND ENSURNG
THAT BOTH MEN WALK OUT OF THIS
CASE ALIVE.
SPEAKER:  HOW CAN YOU SAY THAT
WHEN THE ONLY REASON SHE WENT TO
VELARIO AND THEN WENT TO VENICE
WAS IN THE INTEREST OF HER
HUSBAND?
SPEAKER:  YOUR HONOR, PORTIA AS
A WOMAN IN 16TH CENTURY VENICE,
HAD VERY LIMITED OPPORTUNITIES
TO PURSUE A CAREER.  [LAUGHTER].
THIS WAS AN OPPORTUNITY, NOT
ONLY TO SAVE THE LIFE OF A
FRIEND OF HER HUSBAND, BUT ALSO
TO PUT HER LEGAL EDUCATION TO
USE.  SHE KNEW THAT DR. BELARIO,
HER COUSIN, WOULD PROPERLY
RECOMMEND HER.  AND DR. BELARIO
WOULD NOT RECOMMEND A COUSIN WHO
COULD NOT PROVIDE LEGAL ADVICE,
MUCH LESS A FEMALE COUSIN TO
SEND INTO COURT, PUTTING HIS OWN
REPUTATION ON THE LINE,
PROVIDING ADVICE TO THE DUKE OF
VENICE.  DR. BELARIO WAS A
CAREER MEMBER IN THE COMMUNITY
AND WOULD NOT HAVE PUT HIS
ENTIRE CAREER ON THE LINE FOR
PORTIA.  YOUR HONOR, I SEE
MY
TIME IS UP.  IF I MAY JUST
CLOSE THAT PORTIA REQUESTS ONCE
AGAIN THAT SHE BE RELIEVED FROM
THIS CASE.  PORTIA DID NOT HAVE
A CONFLICT OF INTEREST AND HER
APPEARANCE AS A MAN DID NOT
AFFECT THE OUTCOME OF THIS CASE
AND SHE WAS QUALIFIED TO GIVE
LEGAL ADVICE AND SHYLOCK WOULD
HAVE MURDERED ANTONIO AND
SHYLOCK HIMSELF WOULD HAVE BEEN
EXECUTED.  RATHER PORTIA,
DESPITE ATTEMPTS OVER AND OVER
AGAIN TO CONVINCE SHYLOCK TO
SHOW MERCY, SAVED BOTH SHYLOCK
AND ANTONIO'S LIVES WITH
SKILLFUL NAVIGATION OF VENETIAN
LAW AND EVEN IF THE COURT DOES
NOT AGREE THAT THEY ACTED
SINCERELY, THE APPELLE IN THIS
CASE IN THE CITY ALONE.  PORTIA
WAS MERCIFUL AND IN THAT SPIRIT,
WOULD BE WHOLLY IN FAVOR OF
THIS COURT REDUCING THE VENICE'S
ORDER THAT SHYLOCK CONVERT TO
JUDAISM, JUST AS PORTIA WOULD
HAVE LIKED TO HAVE FREELY AND
OPENLY PRACTICED LAW IN 16TH
CENTURY VENICE AND SO SHE
PERSISTED.  [APPLAUSE]. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR GENEROUS TIME AND
YOUR MERCIFUL ATTENTION.
[APPLAUSE].
SPEAKER:  EACH COUNSEL WILL NOW
HAVE TWO MINUTES OF
[APPLAUSE].
SPEAKER:  EACH COUNSEL WILL NOW
HAVE TWO MINUTES OF
REBUTTAL.
SPEAKER:  YOUR HONOR, I'M GOING
TO BE VERY BRIEF.  BUT I WOULD
LIKE TO ADDRESS A FACTUAL POINT
THAT I THINK IS VERY IMPORTANT
THAT HAS COME UP.  COUNSEL FOR
ANTONIO AND FOR THE REPUBLIC OF
VENICE HAS TRIED TO TOTALLY TURN
THE FACTS ON THEIR HEAD AND
SOMEHOW ANTONIO HAS HAD THE
FINANCIAL WINDFALL AND FORCED
SHYLOCK TO CONVERT TO
CHRISTIANITY, SOMEHOW HE IS THE
VICTIM.  AND THERE REALLY ISN'T
ANY EVIDENCE IN THE RECORD TO
SUPPORT THAT.  AND I WOULD LIKE
TO JUST POINT OUT TWO THINGS
THAT JUSTICE GINSBURG POINTED US
TO.  OBVIOUSLY WHEN HE ENTERED
INTO THIS BOND, HE NEVER THOUGHT
IT WOULD COME DUE.  HAD
MULTIPLE SHIFTS AT SEA AND ONLY
THROUGH HIS BAD FORTUNE THAT THE
BOND ITSELF CAME DUE.  AND THE
SECOND POINT IS THAT CHIEF
JUSTICE GINSBURG POINTED OUT
THAT ANTONIO IS A MAN, AND IT
DOESN'T MAKE A LOT OF SENSE THAT
HE HAS BEEN VICTIMIZED HERE.
AND STRANGE ASPECT OF ALL THE
FACTS IS THAT AFTER THIS
PROCEEDING WHERE ANTONIO HAS HAD
THIS INCREDIBLE VICTORY THAT
TOTALLY HAS NO BASIS IN LAW, WE
DON'T SEE HIM CELEBRATING.  WE
DON'T SEE HIM EXCLAIMING.  WE
REALLY NEVER SEE THAT.  AND SO,
I WOULD JUST SUBMIT TO THE COURT
TO THE VIEW THAT HE HAS BEEN
SOMEHOW VICTIMIZED BY MY CLIENT.
THANK YOU.  [APPLAUSE].
SPEAKER:  I HAVE TWO CLIENTS,
ANTONIO AND THE DUKE OF
VENICE.
AND THE DUKE IS PRIMARILY
CONCERNED THAT JUSTICE BE DONE
AND HE HAD NO IMAGINE OF THE
MASCERADE PORTIA.  AND HE ASKED
ME TO MAKE THE POINT THAT THERE
WERE MISREPRESENTATIONS.  THE
SO-CALLED LETTER OF DR. BELARIO
WHO WAS READ
IN COURT RECITES THAT BALTHIZAR
VISITED HIM AND WENT OVER THE
COURT CASES AND THE LAW.  NOT
THAT PORTIA HAD ANY
PARTICIPATION IN THAT.  AND THEN
PORTIA SPEAKING TO
NURISSA, SAYS ABOUT THE UPCOMING
MASSACRE
MASSACRE, THAT OUR HUSBANDS WILL
SEE US AND THINK SUCH
ACCOMPLISH IN WHAT WE LACK.  IN
OTHER WORDS, SHE WAS ADMITTING
THAT SHE WAS NOT ACCOMPLISHED IN
LAW.
AND THAT SHE WOULD DRESS AS A
LAWYER AND SEEMED TO BE
ACCOMPLISHED WITH WHAT SHE
LACKED.  BUT THE BIG PICTURE IS
THIS.  SHYLOCK HAD A SCHEME TO
MURDER ANTONIO.  A LEADING
CITIZEN OF VENICE.  HE COULD
HAVE BEEN CONVICTED AND
EXECUTED.  THE DUKE SPARED HIS
LIFE.  ANTONIO --
SPEAKER:  WE WERE TOLD BY
PORTIA'S COUNSEL THAT THE ALIEN
ACT WAS A CIVIL MEASURE.
NOTHING ABOUT HANGING.
SPEAKER:  THE LAW, AS IT IS
STATED IN THE RECORD, GIVES THE
DUKE ABSOLUTE DISCRETION AS TO
WHETHER OR NOT TO HAVE EXECUTED
ANY PERSONS WHO VIOLATE THE
ALIEN ACT.  NOT SIMPLY CIVIL
NATURE.  THE DUKE HERE WAS
MERCIFUL.  ANTONIO HIMSELF GAVE
UP THE HALF SHARE OF SHYLOCK'S
FORTUNE THAT HE COULD HAVE
CLAIMED ON THE MILD CONDITION
THAT SHYLOCK GIVE IT TO HIS
DAUGHTER AND SON-IN-LAW UPON HIS
DEATH.  JUSTICE WAS DONE HERE.
RECOGNIZE THAT.  THANK YOU.
SPEAKER:  THANK YOU, COUNSEL.
[APPLAUSE].
SPEAKER:  I HAVE TO CLARIFY THE
ACT ABOUT BEING A CIVIL FORCEFUL
MEASURE.
SPEAKER:  YOUR HONOR, THE POINT
THERE -- SO THE ALIEN ACT DOES
SAY THAT ANY NON-CITIZEN OF
VENICE WHO INTENDS -- WHO
ATTEMPTS MURDER OR COMMITS
MURDER, EITHER DIRECTLY OR
INDIRECTLY COULD BE
PUNISHABLE BY DEATH OR
FORFEITURE OF THE STATE AND
PORTIA DESCRIBED TO THE DUKE OF
VENICE.  AND IT NEVER WENT TO A
CRIMINAL MATTER.
THERE ARE VERY DISCRETE STEPS IN
VENICE, STARTING WELL BELOW THE
16TH CENTURY AND HOW CRIMINAL
CASES ARE HANDLED.  AND THEY ARE
NOT CONVERTED FROM A CIVIL CASE
TO A CRIMINAL CASE ON THE FLY
IN A COURTROOM.  THERE ARE
TRAINED PROSECUTORS THAT BRING
CHARGES.
AND THERE ARE SEPARATE TRIALS IN
CRIMINAL MATTERS IN VENICE IN
THE 16TH CENTURY.  WHAT HAPPENED
HERE IS THAT THE LAW WAS
INTERPRETED AS A CIVIL
FORFEITURE CASE.  SHYLOCK WAS
NEVER IN JEOPARDY OF LOSING HIS
LIFE OR LOSING HIS LIBERTY.
SIMPLY OF SIMPLE FORFEITURE OF
THE STATE.  I WOULD LIKE TO
ADDRESS NOW THE TWO POINTS THAT
CO-APELLEE FOR ANTONIO RAISED.
FIRST, THE DUKE SAID HE WAS
RECEIVING LEGAL ADVICE FROM
BELTHAZAR AND CO-APPELLEE IS
BRINGING GENDER INTO THIS CASE.
SOMEONE WHO WAS TRAINED IN THE
LAW NAMED BELTHAZAR AND
DR. BELARIO KNEW WELL THAT
PORTIA WAS HIDING HERSELF BY
BELTHAZAR AND AS A WOMAN, HAS NO
BEARING ON THIS CASE NO MATTER
WHAT IT WAS.  SECOND, COUNSEL
FOR ANTONIO JUST REFERRED TO ACT
4 SCENE THREE LINE 59.
WHERE NARISSA AND PORTIA, ARE
PREPARING TO
GO TO THE TRIAL.
WHERE PORTIA IS PREPARING TO
DISGUISE HERSELF AS A MAN, TO
PUT ON JUDICIAL ROBES AS WE HAVE
ON TODAY.  WHICH CAN HIDE
ANYONE'S GENDER.  NARISSA ASKS
PORTIA, SHALL THEY SEE US?
REFERRING TO THEIR HUSBANDS.
AND PORTIA RESPONDS, IN FULL,
THEY SHALL, NARISSA, BUT IN SUCH
A HABIT THAT THEY SHALL THINK
THAT WE ARE ACCOMPLISHED WITH
WHAT WE LACK.  I WILL HOLD THEE
ANY WAGER WHEN WE ARE LIKE YOUNG
MEN.  I'LL PROVE THE PRETTIER
FELLOW OF THE TWO.  SHE WAS NOT
-- PORTIA WAS NOT REFERRING TO
THEIR LEGAL EDUCATION.  PORTIA
WAS REFERRING TO WHAT WOULD BE
HIDDEN UNDERNEATH THE ROBES.
UNLESS THIS COURT HAS ANY
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS, WE WILL
REST ON THE PREVIOUS STATEMENTS
MADE IN TERMS OF WHAT PORTIA
DESIRES FROM THIS COURT.
SPEAKER:  THANK YOU, COUNSEL.
SPEAKER:  THANK YOU.
[APPLAUSE].
SPEAKER:  THE COURT WILL TAKE A
RECESS TO
CONFER ON THIS CASE.
SPEAKER: HI.  THIS IS A LITTLE
DIFFERENT THAN AN ORDINARY COURT
PROCEEDING IN WHICH NOW WOULD
BE THE TIME TO GET A CUP OF
COFFEE, CHECK YOUR SMART PHONES,
AND TRY TO GUESS HOW LONG IT
WILL BE BEFORE THE JUSTICES
RETURN.  I HAVE BEEN TASKED WITH
TWO THINGS.  ONE, TO KEEP YOU
ENTERTAINED UNTIL THEY DO IN
FACT RETURN, AND THE OTHER IS TO
PROVIDE A LITTLE INCITE AND
BACKGROUND AS A LITERARY AND
CULTURAL HISTORIAN INTO THE PLAY
AND INTO THE WAY IT MATTERED
BOTH IN SHAKESPEARE'S DAY AND IN
OUR OWN.  IT'S TRICKY, THOUGH,
JUST TO GUESS HOW LONG THEY ARE
GOING TO DELIBERATE.  AND I WAS
IN VENICE WHEN JUSTICE
GINSBURG TOOK ON THIS ROLE LAST
YEAR.  I AM JUST GUESSTIMATING.
I HAVE BEEN INSTRUCTED THAT IF
MY 14 TO 15 MINUTES OF SPEAKING
DOES NOT COVER, I'M GOING TO
TAKE QUESTIONS FROM THE AUDIENCE
UNTIL THEY DO RETURN.  BUT I AM
HOPING TO TIME IT JUST RIGHT.
ABOUT 20 YEARS AGO I WROTE A
BOOK CALLED SHAKESPEARE AND
THE JEWS.  AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I LEARNED IN WRITING
THAT BOOK WAS THE PERSISTENCE
OF VARIOUS MYTHS THAT HAVE
ATTACHED THEMSELVES TO THE
CONNECTION OF SHAKESPEARE AND
JEWS.  TWO OF
THOSE MYTHS CONCERN THE
EXPULSION OF THE JEWS IN 1290
AND THE READMISSION IN 1656.  AS
POINTED OUT, THERE WAS NO
READMISSION IN 1656 AND IN FACT
THERE IS NO
EXPULSION ORDER IN 1290 AND LATE
MID EVIL AND MODERN ENGLAND IS
POORLY UNDERSTOOD AND OFTEN
MISREPRESENTED.  YET ANOTHER
MYTH IS THAT THERE WERE NO JEWS
IN ENGLAND IN SHAKESPEARE'S DAY.
HISTORIANS HAVE SHOWN THAT THERE
ABOUT 150 TO 200 JEWS LIVING IN
LONDON AND BRISTO IN
ELIZABETHIAN, ENGLAND AND HAD
SHAKESPEARE WANTED TO SPEAK TO
ONE.  HE COULD HAVE WENT TO A
CONVERT'S HOUSE ON HOLBORN
STREET AND SPOKE TO A MAN
NETANYAL AND CONVERTED IN LONDON
BY JOHN FOX, MORE FAMOUS FOR
HIS ACTS AND MONUMENTS.  BUT
ALSO A MAN WHO TOOK PLEASURE IN
CONVERTING A NORTH AFRICAN JEW
AND CELEBRATING THAT
BEFORE HIS CHRISTIAN COMMUNITY.
BUT I WOULD MUCH RATHER TALK
TODAY LESS ABOUT THE HISTORY OF
JEWS IN ENGLAND AND
WAYS OF WHICH SOMEONE LIKE ME
WHO HAS BEEN TEACHING PLAYS FOR
YEARS AND ON THE ATLANTIC SIDE
OF IT, THAT EVEN THE MOST
BRILLIANT MINDS SEE IT.  SO I
WILL TRY TO SHARE THAT WITH YOU.
THE DISCUSSION THAT WE HAVE
HEARD QUITE BRILLIANTLY FOR THE
LAST HOUR OR SO, CONCERNS THE
FAMOUS COURTROOM SCENE IN ACT 4
OF SHAKESPEARE'S PLAY.  I SEE IT
IN A RADICALLY DIFFERENT WAY.
CONSIDER PORTIA'S SITUATION.
SHE HAS BEEN MARRIED FOR A VERY
BRIEF TIME TO A VERY HAND SOME
MAN THAT SHE HAS LONG WANTED TO
MARRY.  AND IN THE TIME BETWEEN
THE MOMENT WHERE HE SUCCESSFULLY
CHOSE THE RIGHT CASKET AND THE
MOMENT THAT SHE SPEAKS HER
FAMOUS LINES ABOUT THE QUALITY
OF MERCY, SHE HAS DISCOVERED
THAT THE MAN SHE IS HOPING AND
PLANNING TO SPEND THE REST OF
HER LIFE WITH, IS DEEPLY AND
EMOTIONALLY CONNECTED TO SOMEONE
ELSE.  AND IF SHE HAS ANY
DOUBTS ABOUT THAT, SHE LEARNS IT
AT THIS TRIAL.  HERE IS WHAT
ANTONIO SAYS TO HER HUSBAND,
MOMENTS BEFORE SHE DELIVERS THAT
FAMOUS SPEECH.  THIS IS ANTONIO
TO BESANIO.  COMMEND ME TO YOUR
HONORABLE WIFE.  TELL HER THE
PROSPECTS OF ANTONIO'S END.  SAY
HOW I LOVED YOU.  SPEAK ME FAIR
IN DEATH AND WHEN THE TALE IS
TOLD, LET HER BE JUDGE.  WHEN
BESANIO IS NOT JUST LOVE.
REPENT THAT YOU SHALL LOSE YOUR
FRIEND AND HE REPENTS NOT.  AND
IF IT IS DEEP ENOUGH, I WILL PAY
IT PRESENTLY WITH ALL OF MY
HEART.  AND IF SHE HAS ANY
DOUBTS AT THIS POINT ABOUT
ANTONIO'S INTENTIONS FOR HER
HUSBAND, THIS IS BESANIO'S
RESPONSE DELIVERED BEFORE HER,
ALTHOUGH HE DOESN'T KNOW THAT
PORTIA IS DISGUISED AND IN
COURT.  ANTONIO, I AM MARRIED TO
A WIFE WHICH IS AS DEAR TO ME
AS LIFE ITSELF.  BUT LIFE
ITSELF, MY WIFE AND ALL THE
WORLD ARE NOT WITH ME ESTEEMED
ABOVE THY LIFE.  I WOULD
SACRIFICE THEM ALL, THIS DEVIL,
TO DELIVER YOU.
WHAT IS PORTIA TO DO?  I MEAN,
IF SHE KILLS ANTONIO, JUST
IMAGINE WHAT SHE WILL BE HEARING
FOR THE REST OF HER LIFE FROM
BESANIO.  HE LOVED ME SO MUCH.
MORE THAN YOU DID.  I DON'T KNOW
WHY I ENDED UP WITH YOU AND NOT
HIM.  SHE CAN'T LET ANTONIO
DIE.
BUT IF SHE LET'S ANTONIO LIVE,
SHE IS STUCK IN A LOVE TRIANGLE
THAT SHE COULD NEVER GET OUT OF.
THE BRILLIANCE OF PORTIA IN THIS
SCENE IS THAT SHE RESORTS TO A
LEGAL FICTION, HER MARRIAGE.  IN
SUGGESTING THIS, I AM REALLY
SAYING THAT IN THE MOMENT THAT
IT WAS FIRST STAGED AND FOR THE
FOUR CENTURIES AFTER IT WAS
FIRST WRITTEN, THE MERCHANT OF
VENICE REMAINS A REALLY COMPLEX
AND DEEP WORK OF ART THAT RAISES
MANY MORE QUESTIONS THAN WE CAN
ANSWER EVEN IN THIS MOOD COURT.
IT'S TO DISGUISE PORTIA'S
QUESTION ON ENTERING THE COURT.
WHICH IS THE MERCHANT HERE?  AND
WHICH IS THE JEW TO BE TAKEN
SERIOUSLY?  OR WITHIN SO MANY
PRODUCTIONS IS IT A LIFE LINE?
AS JUSTICE GINSBURG INDICATED
EARLIER, IS PORTIA A RACIST FOR
A DARK SKINNED MUSLIM MOROCCON
PRINCE.  IS ANTONIO SO SAD
BECAUSE OF HIS FINANCIAL WORRIES
OR BECAUSE OF HIS UNSANCTIONED
LOVE FOR
BESANIO WHICH REMAINS.
IS THE PLACE SO TROUBLING
BECAUSE MANY FELT ITS PORTRAYAL
OF SHYLOCK IS NAKEDLY
ANTI-SEMITIC OR IS IT SO
DISTURBING BECAUSE IT DISPOSES
WHAT UGLY MYTHS LEAVE THOSE WITH
INSECURE IDENTITIES, BE IT
CHRISTIAN OR JEW, TO THINK AND
DO WHEN THREATENED AND HOSTILITY
OF ALL KINDS, WHETHER THAT
DIFFERENCE IS RACIAL, NATIONAL,
SEXUAL OR RELIGIOUS, REFORMS
THOSE WHO ARE INTOLERANT AND
ENFORCES ANY SOCIETY THAT
QUESTIONS IT.  THESE ARE THE
QUESTIONS THAT DON'T GO AWAY.
AND FOR ME, AS A CULTURE
HISTORIAN AND THEATER HISTORIAN,
WHAT IS FASCINATING IS HOW THEY
MANIFEST THEMSELVES IN
DIFFERENT TIMES AND IN DIFFERENT
PLACES.
IN NAZI, GERMANY, THIS WAS A
FAVORED PLAY.  STAGED 50
DIFFERENT TIMES AND DIFFERENT
PRODUCTIONS.  ALTHOUGH THOSE
PRODUCTIONS DID NOT ALLOW FOR
THE INTERMARRIAGE OF JESSICA AND
LORENZO.  SOME OF YOU MAY BE
FAMILIAR IN THE LAST WEEK OR SO,
WITH A PROTEST AND CONTROVERSY
AT THE DELACORE THEATER IN
CENTRAL PARK WHERE SHAKESPEARE
PLAYS HAVE BEEN PERFORMED AND
THERE WAS VERY AGGRESSIVE
PROTESTS THAT TRIED TO STOP THAT
PRODUCTION.  THAT WAS THE
PRODUCTION OF
JULIUS CEASOR AND SOME OF YOU
MAY BE LESS AWARE IN 1962, THE
FIRST YEAR IN WHICH THAT THEATER
IN CENTRAL PARK STAGED PLAYS,
IT WAS A DIFFERENT PROTEST, A
PROTEST ABOUT THE MERCHANT OF
VENICE.  AND AN ATTEMPT TO STOP
THE WIDE CIRCULATION AND
DEMONSTRATION OF THAT PLAY.  JOE
PAP IN THAT YEAR HAD THE
EXTRAORDINARY ACTOR AS SHYLOCK.
AND SCOTT'S PORTRAYAL OF
SHYLOCK WAS A REALLY SYMPATHETIC
ONE.  HE LATER SAID AND I
QUOTE, I PLAYED SHYLOCK AS
THOUGH HE WAS DEAD RIGHT AND
THAT HE WAS SCREWED.  BUT THERE
WERE OBJECTIONS NONETHELESS, TO
PERFORMING THIS PLAY IN 1962.
17 YEARS AFTER THE END OF THE
SECOND WORLD WAR, AND THE
EXPOSURE OF THE HOLOCAUST.
MEMBERS OF THE JEWISH WAR
VETERANS PICKETED.  AND THE NEW
YORK BOARD OF RABBIS WROTE TO
THE NEW YORK TIMES, TRYING TO
STOP A TELECAST OF THAT
PRODUCTION WHICH WOULD HAVE GONE
OUT TO 2 MILLION TELEVISION
VIEWERS.  THE RABBIS WROTE AND I
QUOTE, TO PUT IT BLUNTY, THE
PLAY WITH SHYLOCK AS A TYPICAL
JEW AMOUNTS TO DISTORTION AND
DEFAMATION TO THE PEOPLE OF OUR
FAITH.  WHILE I RESPECT THEIR
CONCERNS I BELIEVE THEIR
POSITION IS WRONG.  AND I'LL
SUGGEST THROUGH A FINAL EXAMPLE
WHY IT IS SO DANGEROUSLY SO.
AND WHY WE NEED TO KEEP STAGING
AND NOT CENSORING SHAKESPEARE.
WHEN I FINISHED WRITING MY BOOK,
SHAKESPEARE AND THE JEW, I TOOK
A TRIP TO ISRAEL, AND IT WAS
BACK IN 1994.  AND I WENT TO SEE
A PRODUCTION OF THE MERCHANT OF
VENICE AT THE CAMORY THEATER IN
TEL AVIS.  IT WAS PRETTY WEIRD
AT FIRST.  MY HEBREW IS NOT VERY
GOOD.  IT TOOK A WHILE.  AND
THE ACTOR PLAYING SHYLOCK BEGAN
IN THE EARLY SCENES OF THE PLAY,
AS A SECULAR JEW, HIS HEAD
UNCOVERED WEARING A NICE SUIT.
BUT WHEN HIS DAUGHTER JESSICA
WAS STOLEN AWAY FROM HIM, HE
BECAME RADICALIZED AND HE
STARTED WEARING THE CIPA, OR THE
HEAD COVER OF THE JEW, AND HE
BECAME AGGRESSIVELY FURIOUS AT
EVERYBODY SPRAYING AN
IMAGINATION OOZY AT EVERYBODY
INVOLVED.  AND IT BECAME A VERY
DISTURBING PRODUCTION.  AND IT
WAS A DISTURBING PRODUCTION IN
PART BECAUSE THE DIRECTOR HAD
DONE THIS INTENTIONALLY TO DRAW
ATTENTION TO WHAT HAD HAPPENED
WHILE THIS PLAY WAS BEING
REHEARSED.  AND THAT WAS AN
ATTACK BY SOMEONE LIKE ME WHO
HAD BEEN BORN IN BROOKLYN AND
ACTUALLY GONE TO MY ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL BARUCH GOLDSTEIN WHO HAD
ENTERED THE TOMB OF THE
PATRIACHS AND KILLED
PALESTINIANS AND INJURED
HUNDREDS OF OTHERS, AND IT WAS
TRYING TO ENGAGE WITH THAT IN A
VERY DIRECT WAY.  ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I LOVE ABOUT THEATER
AND SHAKESPEARE IN PARTICULAR
IS THE WAY IN WHICH THESE WORKS
ARE SOMEHOW ABLE TO GET AT
THINGS WHICH NEWSPAPERS, RADIO,
MEDIA TODAY DON'T GET AT.  THEY
HAVE, IF YOU WILL, A PREDICTIVE
QUALITY.  AND ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I ENJOYED SO MUCH ABOUT THE
MOOD COURT THAT I TOUCHED SO
MUCH UPON TODAY, ARE MANY OF THE
ESSENTIAL ISSUES THAT WE ARE
STILL WRESTLING WITH TODAY.
ACCESS TO EDUCATION, ALIENS, THE
RIGHTS OF WOMAN TO EQUAL
EDUCATION AND THE LIKE.  THIS
PRODUCTION AT THE CAMERY THEATER
IN 1994 ALSO STRANGELY HAD A
PREDICTIVE QUALITY.  ABOUT SIX
OR EIGHT MONTHS AFTER I SAW THAT
PRODUCTION, A MAN NAMED UGAL
AMIR CUT FROM THE VERY SAME
CLOTH THAT SHYLOCK MORPHED INTO
SHOT RABBIN SHORTLY AFTER THE
CORDS HAD BEEN SIGNED, AND PUT
AN END TO THAT POSSIBILITY OF
PEACE IN THE MIDDLE EAST.
AND IT'S EXTRAORDINARY TO ME AS
I STILL REFLECT ON IT, 20 SOME
ODD YEARS LATER, THE WAYS IN
WHICH A PERFORMANCE OF
SHAKESPEARE'S PLAY CAN TELL US
SOMETHING ABOUT WHAT IS BUBBLING
UP WITHIN THE CULTURE.  I'LL
STOP AT THIS POINT.  AND I WILL
TAKE QUESTIONS FROM THE
AUDIENCE.  THERE IS ONE IN THE
FRONT ROW.  I'M GOING TO DO,
SINCE THIS IS BEING TAPED, IS I
WILL REPEAT THE QUESTION.  AND
IF I DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER TO
IT, I WILL TURN IT INTO A
QUESTION THAT I CAN ANSWER.
SURE.  THE QUESTION IS.  WHAT
ABOUT THE FACT THAT SHAKESPEARE
WROTE THIS PLAY IN RESPONSE TO
OR REBUTTAL TO CHRISTOPHER
MARLO'S PLAY THE JEW OF MALTA.
THESE ARE REALLY VERY, VERY
DIFFERENT PLAYS.  AND YOU CAN
SAY THAT HE WROTE THE PLAY IN
REBUTTAL TO.  SOME MIGHT BELIEVE
THAT HE WROTE THE PLAY IN A
SENSE TO CAPITALIZE ON THE
INTEREST IN JEWISH QUESTION.
I'M A JEWISH GUY FROM BROOKLYN.
BUT I'LL BE THE FIRST TO ADMIT
THAT SHAKESPEARE AND MARLO
WERE NOT REALLY INTERESTED IN
LIVING JEWS, EVEN THOUGH THERE
WERE 100 OR SO LIVING AMONGST
THEM.  THEY WERE INTERESTED IN
JEWS BECAUSE JEWS ENABLED THEM
TO UNDERSTAND THEIR OWN CULTURE
AT A MOMENT OF GREAT -- HOW
SHOULD I PUT IT, GREAT CHANGE.
IN SHAKESPEARE'S DAY,
EVERYBODY'S GRAND PARENTS HAD
BEEN CATHOLIC, A
PRODESTANT AND CHANGED BACK TO
CATHOLOCISM AND A RELIGION THAT
WAS ONCE SO STABLE IS NOW
UNSTABLE.
INTERNATIONAL RELATIONS BETWEEN
CHRISTIANS, JEWS AND MUSLIMS
WERE FAR MORE COMPLICATED IN AGE
THAN OF EMPIRE.  AND NOTIONS OF
WHAT CONSTITUTED A NATION OR A
RACE OR PEOPLE, ALL OF WHICH
BUBBLE-UP IN PLAY AND ALL OF
WHICH WAS WRESTLING YEARS LATER.
AND COME INTO PLAY IN
MARLO'S WORK AND SHAKESPEARE.
IT'S A REBUTTAL OF.  I WOULD SAY
THAT BOTH OF THESE PLAYS ARE
WRITTEN AT A MOMENT OF
UNCERTAINTY.
AND TWO OF THE GREATEST
DRAMATISTS WHO WROTE IN ENGLAND,
RETURN THE QUESTION OF
JEWISHNESS AS A WAY TO TRY TO
HELP ENGLISH PLAY GOERS AT THE
TIME, WRESTLE WITH THEIR OWN
CONFLICTED IDENTITIES.  MORE
QUESTIONS?  AND HOPEFULLY
JUSTICE GINSBURG WILL RETURN
WITH A VERDICT.  ANOTHER
QUESTION?  I'LL COME FORWARD.
WHAT DO I ATTRIBUTE THE
INTENSE KNOWLEDGE THAT
SHAKESPEARE HAD OF THE LAW?
SHAKESPEARE CARED ABOUT THE LAW
AND LIKE MANY IN HIS LETIGIOUS
DAY, HAD A LOT OF LEGAL INTEREST
AND A LOT OF LEGAL
CONTROVERSIES.  THIS WAS A MAN
WHO WROTE 36 OF THE GREATEST
PLAYS IN ENGLISH AND ALSO
PURSUIT DEATH FOR 7 POUNDS.  HE
ACTUALLY CARED.  BECAUSE HE WAS
INVOLVED IN SO MANY REAL ESTATE
CASES, HE HAD A VEST AND
INTEREST IN THAT AND HAD A VEST
AND INTEREST SECURING FOR HIS
FATHER, AND HEIRS, A CODE OF
ARMS.  SO ALMOST EVERYWHERE
SHAKESPEARE TURNED IN THE PERIOD
IN WHICH HE WAS A PLAY WRITE
AND A SHAREHOLDER IN A THEATER
AND A JOINT STOCK COMPANY, HE
HAD VERY PARTICULAR LEGAL
INTERESTS TO PROTECT AND I THINK
SHAKESPEARE WAS A PRETTY FAST
STUDY AND I THINK HE WAS A
PRETTY FAST STUDY WHEN IT CAME
TO THE LAW AND I THINK HE WAS
THE BEST LISTENER.
WE DON'T ATTRIBUTE SHAKESPEARE'S
LISTENING ABILITIES AS HIGH AS
WE ATTRIBUTE HIS WRITING
ABILITIES, I SUPPOSE.  BUT I'M
SURE HE SAT DOWN WITH MORE THAN
ONE OR TWO LAWYERS AND BOUGHT
THEM DRINKS AND PUMPED THEM FOR
ALL OF THE INFORMATION HE COULD
GET.  NONE QUITE AS BRILLIANT AS
JUSTICE
GINSBURG BUT ENOUGH TO WRITE
QUESTIONS LIKE THIS.  NEXT
QUESTION PLEASE.
SPEAKER:  I HAVE TWO QUESTIONS.
ONE, DO YOU THINK THERE IS ANY
CONNECTION TO THE THEORY THAT
SHAKESPEARE'S FAMILY WAS SECRET
CATHOLICS?  AND TWO, HOW WOULD
YOU SUMMARIZE THE MAJORITY OF
LITERARY CRITIC VIEW OF SHYLOCK,
GIVEN THAT THE SPEECH HAVE NOT
A JEW, EYES, ET CETERA, IS IT
BY AND LARGE THROUGH THE AGES
ESPECIALLY IN THE 20 AND 21ST
CENTURY, POSITIVE AND NEGATIVE.
SPEAKER:  I'LL ANSWER THE FIRST
QUESTION FIRST.  WE HAVE NO IDEA
WHAT SHAKESPEARE'S POLITICAL
BELIEFS WERE.  WE DON'T KNOW
WHETHER HE LIKED DOGS OR CATS OR
WHAT.  ALL WE HAVE IS 36 PLAYS
AND BIOGRAPHICAL EVIDENCE AND
ONE OF THE DANGERS IS LEAVING
THE LIGHT OUT OF THE WORK.  WHAT
IS DANGEROUS, DOESN'T SPEAK
WHAT HIS VIEWS ARE IN THE PLAYS.
HE CREATES CHARACTERS WHO
EXPRESS VIEWS WHICH TEND TO
COLLIDE WITH OTHER VIEWS.  AND
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT IS LOST
WHEN I'M SITTING IN THE HOUSE AT
THE DELECOURT, LISTENING TO
PEOPLE CONFUSED ABOUT
IDENTIFYING SHAKESPEARE'S VIEWS
OF TERRONY VISA VIE CEASOR.
SHAKESPEARE HIDES HIS OWN VIEWS.
AND IF HE WANTED TO EXPRESS
THEM, HE COULD HAVE BEEN THE
GREATEST PREACHER OF HIS DAY.
BUT THAT'S NOT WHAT HE DECIDED
TO DO FOR A LIVE.
THANK GOD.  THE SECOND QUESTION
IS WHAT DO SHAKESPEARENS THINK
OF SHYLOCK?  ARE THEY PRO OR
CON?  I HAVE TO TELL YOU.
MONDAYS, WEDNESDAYS AND FRIDAYS
I AM SYMPATHETIC TO HIM AND
TUESDAYS, THURSDAYS AND SUNDAYS
I AM LESS SO.  I THINK FOR ME,
THE HONEST ANSWER TO THAT
QUESTION IS, WHAT IS MORE
IMPORTANT IS TO SEE WHAT THE
PLAY MEANS IN HISTORY.  HOW IT
SPILLS OUT IN DIFFERENT TIMES
AND DIFFERENT PLACES.  THERE IS
A WONDERFUL FILM, LITTLE KNOWN
IN PART BECAUSE IT'S IN HEBREW
THAT CAME OUT AFTER THE 6TH DAY
WAR AND IT'S AVANTI POPULO AND
ONE OF THE GREATEST MOMENTS THAT
TOUCHED ON THIS PLAY.  AND IN
THIS PLAY, ISRAELI TUNE HAS
DEFEATED IN THE SINAI DESERT,
THE EGYPTIAN ONES, SCRIPTED IN
THE '67 WAR AND THE EGYPTIAN
SOLDIERS ARE DYING OF THIRST.
AND THE EGYPTIAN SOLDIER WHO IS
AN ACTOR IN REAL LIFE, GOES UP
AND TRIES TO GRAB
A CANTEEN OF ONE OF THE ISRAELI
SOLDIERS AND PICKED UP AND
DROPPED AGAIN.
THEY SPEAK ARABIC.  THEY SPEAK
HEBREW.  ENGLISH IS THE ONLY
THING THEY SHARE.  AND SAID IN
THE FIRST ENGLISH SPOKEN IN THIS
FILM.  I AM A JEW.  HAVE NOT I.
AND IT'S A BREATH TAKING MOMENT
THAT RESOLVES THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THESE TWO OPPOSING
FORCES AND ACTUALLY A BRIEF
WHILE, BEFORE A TRAGIC ENDING,
JOIN FORCES.  SO I GUESS MY
ANSWER IS, I'M LESS INTERESTED
IN WHAT STEVEN
GREENBLAT OF HARVARD SAYS, BUT
I'M INTERESTED IN WHAT THE PLAY
TELLS US ABOUT OURSELVES AND OUR
CULTURAL MOMENTS ABOUT
OURSELVES OVER TIME.  YES?
SPEAKER:  UNLESS I'M
INTERPRETING THIS WRONG, IT
SEEMS THAT SHAKESPEARE WAS
INCREDIBLY PROGRESSIVE WITH HIS
VIEWS ABOUT WHETHER IT WAS A
WOMAN OR WHETHER IT WAS ABOUT A
MAN LOVING ANOTHER MAN, ET
CETERA, HOW DO WE ACCOUNT FOR
THAT?
SPEAKER:  I THINK SHAKESPEARE
HAD HIS
FINGER ON THE AGE.  I'M GETTING
OFF THIS STAGE QUICKLY.
OUR JURISTS HAVE RETURNED.
THANK YOU.  [APPLAUSE].
SPEAKER:  THE COURT HAS REACHED
A UNANIMOUS JUDGMENT.  BUT
BEFORE I ANNOUNCE IT, WE ALL
AGREE THAT SHYLOCK,
ANTONIO, AND PORTIA WERE
REPRESENTED BY MOST
EXCELLENT COUNSEL.  [APPLAUSE].
SO TO START TOEXCELLENT COUNSEL.
[APPLAUSE].
SO TO START TO OUR JUDGMENT, AS
SHYLOCK'S ADVOCATE CONCEDED, ITS
POUND OF FLESH IS OUT OF THE
CASE SO THAT IS OFF THE TABLE.
WE ARE ALSO GOING TO HOLD
SHYLOCK TO HIS STATEMENT, THAT
HE WANTED NOT A DROP OF
INTEREST.  SO HE GETS INTEREST.
BUT HE DOES GET BACK HIS
PRINCIPLE.  AS A SUBSTITUTIONAL
REMEDY, BECAUSE HE DIDN'T
GET THE POUND OF FLESH.  AND
THE CONVERSION WAS ONLY ONE
PARTY WHO WAS STILL INSISTING ON
THE CONVERSION.  BUT WE ARE
GOING TO TAKE COUNSEL FOR
PORTIA'S GOOD ADVICE, THAT THE
CONVERSION SHOULD BE
VACATED.  SO SHYLOCK GETS HIS
MONEY BACK BECAUSE OTHERWISE,
ANTONIO WOULD BE
UNJUSTLY ENRICHED.  AND THE
FORFEITURE THAT IS OUT BECAUSE
THE DUKE EXPLAINS THAT THIS
ALIEN STATUTE LEAVES IT IN HIS
JUDGMENT, WHETHER TO TAKE
SHYLOCK'S LIFE, SO THAT IS A
CRIMINAL SANCTION, THEREFORE THE
ALIEN STATUTE IS OUT OF THE
CASE.
AND WE ALSO GRANT PORTIA'S
MOTION TO BE DISMISSED FROM THE
PROCEEDINGS.  AND THAT'S THE SUM
OF IT.  [APPLAUSE].
AND
AND NOW
I THINK EACH OF MY COLLEAGUES
WILL COMMENT BRIEFLY.
SPEAKER:  I WILL START US OFF.
WHAT A PLEASURE IT HAS BEEN TO
SEVEN WITH MY THREE
SISTERS AND ONE BROTHER ON THE
BENCH.  WHAT A PLEASURE TO HEAR
FROM THE ABLE COUNSEL AND TO BE
A PART OF THIS.
MIGUEL-STEARNS, YOU WERE SUCH A
WONDERFUL ADVOCATE FOR YOUR
CLIENT.  AND I HOPE YOU TELL HER
I THINK SHE WOULD BE A REALLY
WONDERFUL CANDIDATE FOR
ADMISSION TO WAKE FOREST LAW
SCHOOL.  [APPLAUSE].
SPEAKER:  I WANTED TO THANK THE
LAW LIBRARY HERE AT THE LIBRARY
OF CONGRESS FOR WHAT THEY HAVE
DONE AND THE
COMM ESHINGS MEMORY OF APRIL
23RD.  AND I AM BEING REMINDED
WHEN HE ONCE SAID, DAMN, THOSE
ANCIENTS HAVE STOLEN MY THOUGHTS
AND WHEN I THINK OF SHAKESPEARE
AND I THINK OF THE MERCHANT OF
VENICE AND ALL OF THOSE LINES
THAT WE HAVE HEARD AND WHAT THEY
SIGNIFY, YOU KNOW THERE IS SO
MUCH IN THAT.  THERE IS SO MUCH
PERCEPTION, PROVOCATION,
SENTIMENTALITY AND HUMOR IN THE
PLAY.  AND AS IT HAS BEEN
DEPICTED.  AND I DO WANT TO SAY
ALSO THAT I THINK THE COUNSELS
WERE FANTASTIC.  I ENJOYED BEING
WITH THE JUDGES AND TO ME,
JUSTICE GINSBURG IS A ROLE MODEL
AND AN IDOL AND I VERY MUCH
PREACH HER BEING
HERE.  AND THANK YOU FOR
SETTING IT UP, TOO.  AND YOU
HAVE BEEN A GREAT AUDIENCE.  THE
ENTHUSIASM HAS BEEN THERE AND
THE HUMOR AND UNDERSTANDING.
THANK YOU.
SPEAKER:  THANKS.  I ADD MY
THANKS AS EXPRESSED BY THE
HONORABLE REYNOLDS AND MORELLA
AND MY APPRECIATION TO EVERYONE
FOR PUTTING THIS ON AND SUCH A
WONDERFUL PERFORMANCE BY
EVERYBODY.  IT WAS GREAT.  IN
THE 18TH CENTURY, PEOPLE COULD
NOT ACCEPT PEOPLE, WHEN I SAY
PEOPLE OF THE ENGLISH, I AM
THINKING MOSTLY COULDN'T ACCEPT
BAD ENDINGS, TRAGIC ENDINGS, SO
THEY CHANGED THE ENDINGS OF
SEVERAL PLAYS.  CHANGED THE
ENDING OF KING LEER FOR EXAMPLE
TO MAKE SURE THAT CORNELIUS
LIVES AND GOES APPLE TO APPLE
AND CHANGE THE FEELING OF
HAMLET.  SO THEY GET MARRIED.  I
FEEL LIKE, TO A CERTAIN EXTENT,
THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE
DOING WHEN WE HAVE THIS
PERIODICALLY REPEATED APPEAL OF
SHYLOCK.  I FEEL LIKE WE ARE
SOMEHOW ADDING OUR OWN ENDING TO
A VERY SAD STORY THAT
SHAKESPEARE TOLD ABOUT EXCLUDING
PEOPLE AND EXCLUDING GROUPS OF
PEOPLE, WOMEN AND JEWS AND
MOROCCANS WAS BROUGHT UP HERE
AND WE CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE WITH
THIS AS A SOCIETY AND OUR DOING
THIS IS REALLY, IN THIS SENSE,
READDING ANOTHER ENDING.
GETTING ANOTHER CHANCE OF
FINDING SOME JUSTICE HERE.  IT
HAS BEEN GREAT TO BE PART OF
THAT PROCESS.  AND I HAVE TO SAY
AS WELL FROM THE HEART THAT YOU
KNOW, I SO APPRECIATE JUSTICE
GINSBURG AGAIN DOING THIS IN
VENICE LAST SUMMER AND NOW DOING
IT AGAIN.
SHE IS ALSO FOR ME AN INCREDIBLE
IDOL AND ROLE MODEL.  AND I
THANK HER FOR AGREEING TO DO
THIS.  [APPLAUSE].
SPEAKER:  I WANTED TO SAY THANK
YOU TO THE LAW LIBRARY FOR
INVITING ME.  IT HAS BEEN A VERY
GREAT EXPERIENCE.  ESPECIALLY
WITH SUCH A DISTINGUISHED PANEL.
AND I AM ALSO GLAD THAT THE
UNITY HAS BEEN RESTORED.  EVEN
WITH A LITTLE BIT OF DELAY.  BUT
AS BEING AS ITALIAN, I KNOW
THAT JUSTICE MIGHT BE SLOW.  SO
I AM HAPPY THAT YOU FINALLY GOT
IT.
[APPLAUSE].
SPEAKER:  OKAY.  THE CAST HAS
AGREED TO TAKE A FEW QUESTIONS.
AND SO WE HAVE SOME MICROPHONES
OUT IN THE AUDIENCE.  SO PLEASE
RAISE YOUR HAND.  AND THEY WILL
HAND YOU A MICROPHONE.  YOU CAN
ASK ANY OF THE CAST MEMBERS,
EXCEPT ME, QUESTIONS AND DIRECT
THEM.  OR YOU CAN JUST ASK
GENERAL QUESTIONS.  OKAY.  I
DON'T THINK WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS.  MAYBE WE HAD
QUESTIONS BEFORE.  [APPLAUSE].
BUT I DO WANT TO, ON BEHALF OF
THE LAW LIBRARY OF CONGRESS, I
WOULD LIKE TO THANK ALL OF THE
CAST MEMBERS AND SPEAKERS
TONIGHT.  AND LET ME ALSO THANK
SHYLOCK FOR A TERRIFIC
PERFORMANCE.  [APPLAUSE]. AND
ALSO, I WILL ADD MY THANKS TO
JUSTICE GINSBURG BECAUSE THIS IS
A VERY BUSY TIME, AS YOU KNOW,
FOR THE SUPREME COURT.  AND WE
REALLY APPRECIATE HER BEING
HERE.  PLEASE JOIN US UPSTAIRS
IN THE GREAT HALL FOR A